Golden. [music]
[music]
[music] Hey. Hey.
Hey, hey, hey. [music]
[music]
Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
[music]
>> streets. [music] Wall Streets 2 million
in taxes for hood is crazy. I used to be
that half a brick key baby now that real
estate [music]
boy dream to make a million that off
play. We made a million in [music] the
day. Tell me how we go from
[music] sides but I trade stocks for the
low like selling work [music] in that up
money secure. I got in I got out keeping
[singing] all glory to God. Hold up.
This ain't me. [music] Tell me how we
went from trapping to rapping on BET.
Last week I told invested to the Kansas
City Chiefs. Golden rule to invest and
make that money while you [music] sleep.
They say trapper perfect.
No more shoe box money portfolio.
[music and singing] Golden rule to
invest and make that money while you
sleep. I'm gone.
What's good? What's good? What's good,
family? It's your boy, the Wall Street
Trapper, and welcome to another episode
of Trapping Tuesday.
[applause]
Okay,
bet you heard me. [laughter]
All right, man. So, first and foremost,
what I would like to say is thank you
from bottom of my heart, man. I just
want everybody know everybody to
understand that like without you there
is no Wall Street Trapper man. Without
y'all there is no Freedom Center, man.
Without y'all there is no Wall Street.
Looks like us now. So from the bottom of
my heart, man, 206 episodes in, man.
That's over four years of doing this
thing, man. Actually, this month
actually makes four years. We started
this in August 2022, man. And this makes
four years that be we've been doing
this. The goal wasn't to get to 200. The
goal is just keep serving the people.
And I want to stand front and center
that says this.
Black people, I love us.
I I want to get front and center and say
that black people, I love us. Black
people, you made me.
You are responsible for the growth. you
are responsible for
uh the path.
You know what I'm saying? Like outside
of just God giving me this Godgiven
ability, it is because of you. It is
because the likes. It is because of the
shares. It is because of the repost. It
you helped to build me. You gave me
reason. You gave me purpose. You
increased my courage. You increase my
power. You increase my voice. You
increase my influence. And it's nothing
against no other race, color, or creed.
I love y'all all for but black people.
You made me. And I would never in my
life ever ever forget [music] that.
I will never in my life forget that
because it was us that inspired me. When
I was in the trenches, I saw 99% of
black families around me struggling. I
saw black mamas working two and three
jobs. Me and all my homies was black.
And we watched his auntie on drugs. My
auntie on drugs. My mama in jail. His
mama [music] working two jobs. His mama
a junkie. His mama doing this. His mama
locked up. His mama an alcoholic. His
mama messing with two and three [music]
men trying to get off. And I watched it.
I watched his daddy work on a garbage
truck. His daddy come from prison. His
daddy be a drunk, his daddy be a killer,
his daddy be a ganga, [music] his daddy
be dead, his daddy be dead. And it's
because it was all black people that I
saw.
And I'm just saying that like as we
progress in the culture, yep, bro, we've
come so far in five or six years, like
what I see now is a completely different
um
landscape of first generation
millionaires who know so much about
investing and want to know so much about
real estate and want to know so much
about [music] uh credit and want to know
so much about building a business. I'mma
be honest. Like I didn't see that in 19
I mean in [music] in in 2017 and 2016.
I'm just keeping it real. Like I'll be
honest. Like when I first started this I
I only saw like probably Boyce Watkins
and and nothing against Boyce Watkins,
but like a lot of people didn't really
relate to him cuz it was just Boyce
Watkins. [music] Nothing against Dr.
Boyce Watkins, right? Nobody really
related to him. He had just been in the
game for a while and he was talking his
talk but like nobody really related to
him. Nobody really he felt like he ain't
connect. You know what I'm saying?
Nothing against Dr. Boyce Watkins. Let
me say that again. Nothing against Dr.
Boyce Watkins. It's the difference
between listening to one rap like I
don't really connect with him like that.
So, I'mma hurt him. And we heard Jesus
like that's my guy right there. And so
when I came into the game, it was like
me just like who do I need to hear that
represents me? Who can give me the game
that I need to hear that can make me say
this game is [music] like it? And so
when I started investing in like 2009,
2010, I was doing it to help black
people. [music]
I was doing it because all my homeless
was going to prison. All my homies was
getting shot. I had done got shot. I had
done been in prisons. I was fighting
another charge while I was looking at
another 25 years. And I was like, bro,
like this for us.
I was watching friends [music] that I
was real close to, females that I was
cool with. They was dancing. They was
stripping. And I was like, "Damn, she
too cool to be stripping." Nothing
against the stripping culture, right?
Nothing against that. I'm just [music]
saying when I was doing it, I was like,
"All right, bet." Like, "How can I help
my girl get out the club cuz I'm seeing
her like, "Yep, I just had this dude.
Yep, I just had this dude." And I'm
looking at her trying to feed her kids,
and I'm talking to her, sitting on the
porch smoking with her, and she like,
"Bro, I really don't want to do this,
but I don't got no other way." [music]
Like, I know that pain. I know what
that's like. I I know what it was like
to watch like a couple of my girls who
was in the hood with me like all they
think they as they body. So they selling
cooch, they selling whatever and they
like bro like my kids got to eat this
all I know. I ain't tripping. I'm going
to be the sacrifice.
Like I I don't know how to do nothing
else. Like yeah, I could go do the job
and all that, but I ain't really own
that type of time. Like I'm going to
[music] do this. I'mma is what it is.
And I watched some of my other friends
that was really cool. I watched dudes
use them to go do some other stuff. And
it was like, bro, like I can't live with
that, but that's what I gotta do because
I'm gonna [music] make 10 15 grand. How
else I'm gonna do this and that and it
wasn't even about the Chanel bags and it
wasn't about the Louis Vuitton. Then it
was like, I just want to put some money
up for the kids and I just want to make
sure the lights good for 6 months.
Like this was before the Instagram had
changed like the dynamic of what we
looked at as success and looked at as
wealthy. I come from that. Like I I come
from watching females [music] who set
up. And I come from watching
females who selling their body to
provide. And neither one of them looked
at each other different. And we ain't
look at neither one of them different
because we know we need to do something,
we can go here. Or we need to do
something, we can go here. I'm just
saying when I started this, I started it
for people that look like me. So ain't
no way in world I'mma ever feel like
this ain't because of y'all.
And I know that the culture sometimes
can be like like super critical on us
for making mistakes. I know the culture
can we all can get jammed in sometime as
being scammers when we ain't never
scammed. I know that we all could be
jammed in sometimes when somebody do bad
over here. We all take the fall for. But
guess what fam? That's cuz all of us got
trauma.
All us been messed over. All of us feel
like got [music] something in our heart
that we felt like, man, that ain't for
us. This person should be doing that.
All that come with the game.
And I'm cool with all that, bro. I ain't
never scammed nobody a day in my life.
But you know how many times somebody
called me a scam? I ain't never scanned
about a day in my life. But sometimes
you get bashed over everybody. You got
to fight for that. You got to fight for
[music] your name. You got to fight for
the thing you put it all on the line for
because nobody don't know. But guess
what y'all? Black people like it's us,
man. And we done come a long way.
We done come a long way. And yet and
still it's still not many of us.
Yet and still it's still not a lot of us
know about the stock market. It's a
small group of us that know about the
stock market. It's a small group of us
that know about crypto. It's a small
group of us that know about day trade.
It's a small group of us that know about
swing trade. It's a small group of us
that know about leap options. It's a
small group of us that understand that
we can get in real estate. It's a small
[music] group of us that understand that
we can fix our credit and leverage it.
It's a small group of us that understand
about trust [music] funds. It's a small
group of us that understand about life
insurance. It's a small group of us
that's willing [music] to pay the
investment to get a mentor. It's a small
group of us. So don't never think it's a
whole bunch of us. It's a small small
small group of us, y'all. It's a small
group of us.
And I ain't here to say we all got the
same kumbaya cuz I don't believe that. I
do not believe that competition that
collaboration is better than
competition. I believe that sometimes
you got to compete. But that's how I
show y behind. I just believe that. I
don't believe that we all got to be
cool. I don't believe that. I believe we
can go our separate ways, bro. I believe
we can all do something different
because I understand that in [music] the
end result we kind of all want the same
thing. We just don't agree on how we get
that and that's all right.
That's all right.
But at the end [music] of the day,
y'all, man, we all we got.
At the end of the day, y'all, we all we
got. Cuz at the end of the day, we all
are on the chessboard
and every move that we make is critical
because we playing a game that's way
bigger than us, y'all. We coming from
behind the eightball and we got to fight
so hard just to get break even.
We come from behind the eightball.
Everybody Everybody look at me and be
like, "Trap, bro, your story like that."
I'm like, "Bro, I know 15 other people
the same kind of story."
People hear my story and be like, "Dog,
your story is a movie. your story. I'm
like, bro, I know 10 dudes that probably
way worse than what I come from. I know
dudes who watch their mama go boom after
[music] room after person after person.
I think that I watch my homie be like,
"Bro, I watch the shame on my dog fake
cuz his mama turning tricks for crack."
I watch my dog have to sell his mama
crack cuz he say if I don't sell it to
her, somebody going to sell it to her. I
watch that in person.
I watched my other homie watch his mama
get halfway beat to death and then he
doing 25 years in jail now because he
couldn't take any more and he shot him
and now he home. I said I done watched
it all. I done seen it all.
I done seen it all.
So you see my story. My story ain't no
different. I'm just one of the ones that
made it. I'm one of the ones that said,
"God, like I'm I'm I'm one I'm one of
the ones with the other ones." We prayed
while we was doing dirt.
Like we asking God, "Hey God, if you
help me get through this lick right
here, like I'm going to be all right.
Hey God, if you help me get through this
one right here, I'm going to be all
right." And we going through wrong. And
so I'm just telling you that I ain't
never in position to look down on
nobody. I ain't never in position to
think that I'm better than cuz I done
seen the worst of the worst.
And so when you look at me now, yeah, it
look like, yeah, trap, you disconnect. I
promise you, I ain't I still live with
them scars even though you don't see
them on me, they internal.
And there some nights when I'm in the
shower and I'm crying because I don't
even think that I'm worthy of this
lifestyle cuz of what I done seen. Not
just what I done read in the book of
what I done seen.
And I'm 42 and I've been [music] seeing
it since I was 12. Since I was 13, since
I was 14, since I was 15, since I was
16, I was 17. So I was seeing it longer
than I not seeing it.
And so the residue is in here. It's
baked in.
So when I look at us right now, bro, I
see so much potential in us.
It's nothing against no other race, man.
I don't feel shame about saying Wall
Street look like us now, bro. And that
89% of that the us black.
I'm just keeping it a 100. And if I got
to lose followers behind this one, I
don't care.
cuz all my people from other races who I
rock with, y'all know I rock with y'all.
But it's okay for me to say I won't see
us win too.
It's okay for me to root for the dude in
first and second place in Olympics that
got the black glove on their hand and
still not look bad at the dude in third
place.
It's okay.
Just cuz I'm pro this don't mean I got
to be anti that.
I can be pro this and not be anti that.
I understand as a man who is growing his
faith in God, bro. Only thing I hate is
ignorance.
That's the only thing I hate, bro. I'm
still learning how to hate all the stuff
that God don't like.
But I can answer I hate ignorance. I
hate racism
cuz it keep it keep two people from
actually seeing the good in one another.
So, I'm going to be real, but I ain't
going to never say like, "Nah, bro. This
ain't about No, bro. It is about us.
It is about us. I don't care about not
having a sponsor, bro. Cuz I feel like
it's enough of us to where we [music]
going to support each other. We might
not get it all,
but I don't care about vanity metrics.
[music] If I did, I would have a whole
bunch of people on trapping to get us to
6,000 people every week. If I did, I
wouldn't worry about not doing stuff in
hoodies. If I did, I wouldn't worry
about the baking soda, right? You know
how many people be like, "Bro, if you
take the bacon soda down, you can get
the sponsorship. If you take the triple
beam down, [music] bro, we can get you
100 grand." And I say, "Nah, bro." Cuz
I'm authentically me.
So my evolution comes when I put God in
the front of it. My evolution comes when
I wear my little Tom Ford glasses to
make me look a little intellectual. My
evolution comes when I get a haircut
every week before the show because I
don't care about not having a haircut. I
don't care about not letting the beard
hang out. I did that for weeks and
months at a time. But let me be a little
presentable. My evolution comes when I
took the gold teeth out my mouth and
said, "Let me get all pearly whites."
And I don't want to get them all. It's
just two of them, but I'mma keep the
little yellow ones at the bottom that I
get my teeth cleaned every month. I
don't care if the dude hit me in the
mouth with the lock when I was in
prison. I don't got to go get fake
teeth. I want you to see authentic trap.
I ain't covering the tattoos up. I want
you to see me see, hey, that's my
brother right there. That's my dog right
there. That's my nephew right there.
That's my cousin right there. That's my
homie right there. That's big bro right
there. That's the OG right there. So, I
ain't going to never say it ain't about
us, y'all. It's always about us. Every
day it's about us. When I wake up, it's
about us. When I go to sleep, it's about
us. When I'm dreaming at night, it's
when I'm bought. When I lose a trade,
it's about us. When I win a trade, it's
about us. When I turn on a business
deal, it's about us. When I make one,
it's all about us. When I bought this
building, it's about us. And I don't got
it all figured out, but it's always
about us.
It's always about us. And it's always
going to be about us. Cuz I'm a black
man [music] in America. And I'm raising
a little black girl. So, it's always
going to be about us. I'm a black man in
America that ain't never had his father.
It's always going to be about us. I'm a
black man in America that saw his mama
do drugs. It's going to always be about
us. I'm a black man in America that saw
his mama go to prison and I was swapping
shoes out over there in prison. It's
going to always be about us because I
know I ain't the only one that got to
see somebody that I understand that my
role I understand that who I am inspires
somebody else. I understand when certain
people see me, [music] they see
themselves. When they see me, it give
them permission to grow. So when they
see me keep my cool, it's like say trap,
you gave me permission not to pick that
thing up when I got into it because I
thought about you bro and I said trap
can be resilient. [music] I can be
resilient. If trap can let something
slide, I can let something slide. If
trap can walk away, I can walk away. If
trap can talk about God and still be a
G, then I can say my prayers, too. If
trap could talk about the Bible and
still be a G, then I can talk about the
Bible, too. If trap can just go to
church on Sundays, then I could go to
church, too. If trap can put a suit on,
then I can put a suit on, too. That
don't take the gangster away from me. It
just mean I'm a ganga, but I'm moving
over to a little godly. That mean I'm a
gangster, but I'm still trying to learn
how to be a disciple. I cut your ear
like Peter and then get on my knees and
pray like Paul. I'm just saying it's all
in me. It's always about us. It ain't
going to never be about not about us.
It will never not be about us.
And so I'm going to take the criticism.
I'm cool with it.
I'm cool with it. I'm still fighting
with learning how to let stuff online
go. I'm cool with it. I'm still learning
not how to entertain everything. Cuz if
you caught me four years ago, if I was
on live and you said something, I'm
trying to pull up on you. If you caught
me a couple years ago, you said
something on live, I'm asking you where
you want to meet me at.
I'm still learning. I'm still figuring
it out. The residue of what I come from
is still in me. I'm still learning, fam.
I ain't perfect, but it's always about
us.
And I ain't going to never forget that.
If I become a billionaire one day, guess
what? It's always about us. I get the
100 million, guess what? It's always
about us.
And if they ever told me, trap, you got
to do this, so you can't do this. I'm
going say, "Well, I'm not going to do
this because I won't show them we can do
it this way." It's always about us. I
don't never got to be the biggest, fam.
I don't never got to be the biggest,
bro.
It's always about us.
And I was supposed to talk tonight about
something about freedom. Without
discipline equals destruction, but when
it ain't about us to me, it's
destruction.
Cuz anytime that I do something that
don't represent us in the right way,
that's destruction to me. You know what
the money gave me the obligation
to do
is to represent God in the way that he
cool with also represent you too.
The money gave me the the the freedom to
turn deals down.
The money gave me the freedom to say no.
The money gave me the freedom to say
nah, I'm good on that.
I'm just saying I'm just speaking from
trap perspective.
Like it's always about us, man.
I bought the Freedom Center cuz it was I
named the Freedom Center cuz I wanted
you to see if somebody that look like
you that come from where you come from
own a big old white building.
I wanted you to see that. And the reason
why I use money from the stock market
because I wanted you to see what's
possible.
Maybe you don't get a big old building.
Maybe you buy your first house from
money you made in the market. Maybe you
buy your first duplex from money you
made in the market. Maybe you buy your
first rental car that you're going to
use to [music] from the market. Maybe
you buy your first Airbnb property from
money you made from the market. I just
want to inspire you to do something. I
want you to think outside the box.
That's why I don't got time to be
beefing or going back and forth with
nobody who similar in this space cuz
bro, if we doing that then we really
We really being clowns in a circus.
We really doing exactly what they want
us to do. making money. Look at
they they doing
That's why you can't give them no money.
They going to keep doing
Look at them. Look at their true colors.
I ain't never want to be that.
But again, we don't, man, look, we we
don't got to be all we ain't got to be
all friends, man.
I'm cool with that,
bro. It's always about us, bro.
I remember Wayne said something one time
and the lady asked Wayne like, "How do
you feel knowing that you are a role
model?" And Wayne said, "I ain't sign up
to be no role model." And that's one of
the only things I ain't like when Wayne
said back then was like, "Nah, bro."
Like, you are a role model. when you
start getting money, you start people
start to see you like people start
changing their life around you. People
start being influenced by everything you
say. And [music] so I had to learn that.
I had to learn that sometimes I really
don't feel like talking to people when
they walk up on me. Like sometimes
people walk on me immediately my body go
into a different state. But I had to
realize bro no bro like cuz I would
rather somebody say dang trap cool dude
and say man tra ain't even want to talk
to me [music]
and he phony man he ain't bu like that.
I be with my daughter sometime and I be
praying people see me and be like hey
bro I know you got your daughter trap
but what's good bro it's all love but
sometime they walk on me I'll be like
what's up bro you know I got my little
with me you heard me like oh trap my bad
bro but can I take a picture like I got
my li with me dog like man just catch me
next time I I'll be the one be bled
begging
I'll be the one begging like say bro I
got my little women dog like let me let
me let me give me a pass bro like I'm
the one I got my little women bro just
give me just give me a pass on this one
bro I promise cuz I got you next [music]
time, bro. It's me and my shorty, bro. I
don't mean no disrespect. That's me cuz
it's always about us.
It's always about us. It's never not
about us.
I'd rather do that than be like, "Nah,
man. Bro, you see I got my I want Hey,
bro. Look, I man. Look, bro. [music] I
do want to take the picture with you,
right? I got my little Let me just We in
the airport, bro. It's moving so fast.
If I take the picture with you, somebody
going to smash my li. I'm going to be
messed [music] up, bro. You going to
have your picture now? I got to chase
some man. Just give me this time right
here, bro. I promise I got you next
time,
man. I [music] respect that trap, dog.
It's all That's all I be want. Like,
it's always about us. I'm still learning
empathy.
I'm still learning how to walk around as
the person that I am. And people run up
on me and me not go back into a place in
my head where when people ran up on you
before, it was something else. I got to
tell myself, trap, we ain't been that in
about seven years, bro.
It's always about us. It's never not
about us.
But I do know this,
man. Together we so strong.
Together we so powerful.
Together [music] like we unstoppable
together. We keep planting the seeds.
Like, man, we can look back and be like,
damn, we built a we we we got a forest
together. We can increase the network of
these black families. I don't care if
you want this situation, that situation,
that situation, that situation. Like,
somebody should be listening to one of
us.
We got to take the egos out the way
because without y'all, man, none of us
ain't nothing.
Cuz here's what I will tell you.
that the other groups that support us,
they only make 1% of the other.
99% of our supporters are us.
Just like 99% of Grant Cardone
supporters is him, 99% of Tony Robbins
supporters, 99% of
we us, fam.
So never ever ever forget that.
Never ever ever
forget that.
To my black people, I want y'all to know
something, man. I [music] am the Wall
Street Trapper. And without y'all, I am
nothing. Wall Street Trapping. Trapping
Tuesday, episode 206. Let's get to it,
man. [applause]
Man, the black black hoodie trap. That's
what we got today.
>> Just being trapped. You heard me?
>> Black hoodie trap.
>> Just being trapped, dog. That's all.
>> I ain't mad at you. You had people here
going,
>> huh? what uh what Miss Sherro gave you.
>> Just a cool little Ivy, bro. I ain't do
too much. I ain't even do the NAD, bro.
Just chilling, bro. I just
>> I ain't do the NAD or nothing. I just
did I just did us.
>> Okay.
>> I just did that with the hoodie and the
fresh cut. Oh, we knew we was going to
get something special. [laughter]
We knew we was getting something special
on this one.
>> We knew we was getting something
special.
>> Just, you know,
>> actually that joint is in alignment. So,
you know, we went to Martha's Ve to
celebrate baby girl birthday, right?
>> All right. When I tell you
it's a different vibe, right? Ain't no
ninja type stuff going on. You got
literally people in the streets
literally drinking, but everybody, the
women walk around like they floating.
You got African-American aunties and
grandmas, they graceful. It's like they
got their own fan. They dresses just
flaring, bro. The aunt is out there. And
it ain't no, it's just different. And
one of the things as far as how much
time it take to get there and the money
it take to get there. But I was like,
yo, this is a They don't even lock doors
around that drink.
>> They don't even lock doors
>> or lock doors.
>> Yeah. No lock doors, bro. No lock doors.
It's just a totally different vibe out
that joint.
>> What you mean they don't lock doors?
>> Like literally to the point where it's a
ongoing thing. Like everybody of course
you rent houses when you come out there
and visit.
>> Rent houses.
>> Yeah. Yeah, they you rent the houses and
multiple people kind of be staying in
the houses and everything like that,
>> huh?
>> Like they literally like have like
hotels, these houses, but they call them
kind of like hotels and people are the
hotels.
>> Yeah. So there's no hotels.
>> Uh they do have actual hotels, but they
still big houses. That's on the strip
out like Oak Bluff or whatever. But what
happens when you pull up?
>> They be like, "Hey, nah, just go in the
house. The keys it's unlocked. The keys
be on the counter.
It's a different
>> I've never been to Martha Vineyard.
>> It's a different vibe, bro. It's a
totally different vibe.
>> I've never been to Martha's V.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
Totally different.
>> So, you don't lock the doors?
>> I mean, I of course I lock the doors
once I got in there, but they literally
will let you go walk in the house.
Unlock. People out on the porches just
drinking, having a good time.
>> Like, what do you what do people do out
there
>> really?
events like go, you know,
>> events be at somebody house.
>> They'll have them at like big houses.
They have event houses or what have you
under like um under
>> houses?
>> Yeah. Under like tents or what have you.
>> Tents.
>> Tents. And they'll have different events
like director's brunches or
>> the what?
>> Director's brunch.
[laughter]
>> Okay.
>> They have a lot of different events out
there. And so people do that. They do a
lot of drinking, a lot of eating, a lot
of walking.
>> A lot of drinking.
>> A lot of eating.
>> A lot of walking.
>> And we not locking the doors.
>> They ain't locking the doors.
>> Interesting.
>> It's different. They got the little
polar bear experience.
>> A polar bear. And where's this place?
>> Yeah. That's That's a different Drake.
Basically, you going out at 7:00 in the
morning into the cold into the water.
It's basically something they've been
doing for the last 80 years.
>> So, black people going into cold water.
Cold water.
>> Interesting.
>> Yeah, it's definitely It's one of those
things like hearing it,
you're like, man, nah.
>> Where is
>> going and doing it?
>> Huh?
>> Where is Martha's Vineyard?
>> Mass
Massachusetts.
>> Massachusetts.
>> Yeah.
>> So, we not locking doors.
>> Mhm.
>> In Massachusetts.
>> In that part of Massachusetts. I don't
know what they doing on the mainland.
>> [laughter]
>> Right. You done changed over a new leaf.
[gasps]
>> Interesting.
>> Very. It's different.
>> Do people go there year round?
>> Nah.
>> So, it's cool.
>> They usually like
>> Does it close?
>> Huh?
>> No, it's open. It's just nobody's going
to be around there outside of like the
summer months for real for real.
>> So, nobody goes in the winter?
>> No. There's people who live there.
>> Oh, some people live there.
>> Yeah.
>> This is this is this is like interesting
to me.
>> Yeah. Don't get me wrong. While I was
out there, I was like, "Oh, I need to
look up some stuff on YouTube about the
different stuff out here and how people
who really really live out here." They
were like, "Yeah, it's like a ghost town
in the winter time."
>> H
>> in Massachusetts.
>> Massachusetts.
>> So, we only go in the summer
>> most of the time. Yeah.
>> Like
>> they say what? July to Labor Day. Like
July 4th.
>> So two months.
>> What happens in cold?
>> Huh?
>> It could get cold up there. It's up
north, boy.
>> What's in Massachusetts? [laughter]
>> Why Massachusetts, though?
>> That's a whole thing I'm still learning
about. Why that specific?
>> What is the significance of Martha's
vineyard? Who is Marthur?
>> I don't know who Martha. [laughter]
I don't know who Martha is.
>> Who is Martha?
>> I don't know.
>> How did that vineyard get so popular?
>> I don't know. That's one of the things
that I'm learning about.
I just know it was definitely a
different type of vibe.
>> Was that what Inkwell shot?
>> Yes.
>> See, that's all you had to say. Inkwell.
I would have it would have came to me
like, "Ah,
>> here's the crazy part. I watched it out
there, right?" Cuz I watched it before,
but I didn't remember.
>> Bro, I remember Ink. Well,
>> how we going to let the married chick
smash the 16-year-old boy?
>> Nope. We not doing that. [laughter]
Not doing that. Like, oh, if tables was
turned, riots,
>> we not doing that. I said, oh, y'all we
let this go. Anyh who,
>> we not doing that.
>> Yeah, Inkwell was shot there, though.
>> All right, so that's when Inkwell was
shot. Okay, now I understand the place.
>> Yeah.
>> All right, cool. You should have said
Inkwell. I would I would have kind of
got it then.
>> If you just say Inkwell, like, bro,
that's when Inkwell was like, ah, I get
it.
>> Yeah,
>> that's why I know about Inqua. I
remember hearing Ah, bet. Good job.
>> All right. It's like that, too. M let's
get it, man. Uh let's shout out to our
people, man.
>> Yeah.
>> Um Pascal, what's good, man? Uh
Belinda,
uh it's it ain't Oh, it ain't say it
ain't Boston Trap. Thank you for that.
All right. Uh Mark Slade 906, what's
good? Paul Bricks, I see you. Carolina
Blue, I see you. Uh Jaylen Smith,
[laughter]
what's good? Gino Gino B368 was 360.
What's good? Uh Trent Treersonson
1206. What's good? Uh
Sir James, what's good? Not Martha
Stewart. Miss Spy Healing, I see you.
Lawn Care Trapper, what's good? Will Mac
33, what's good?
[laughter]
He say, "Man, Trap go keep the snacks
all that." That's good, man. Y'all
blowing trap mama m for sure. Davon,
what's good? Shame on Walsh, what's
good? Carolina Blue, what's good?
Professor Pat, what's good? IMC, what's
good? Doug Perry 11, what's good? Double
R, what's good? Blacks 592 Investor,
what's good? Leon Barnes, what's good?
My dead monster, what's good? Uh, KB
Mississippi Trapper, what's good? Uh,
Nola Kid, what's adding, man? Ashley, no
love, what's good, beloved. Jay Douglas
68, what's good? Shawn Pay, what's good?
Professor Pat, what's good? Ernso 23,
what's good? Osiah, I hope I said that
right.
Now, your name went fast. I saw you,
bro, but I for it. It went by too fast.
Mr. Week 93, what's good?
Chuck Chucky B from the trap, what's
good? Stage 2 trader, what's good? Wall
Street Mac, what's good? Stello 76,
what's good? Boogie Down502, what's
good?
Mazari 999, what's good? DB the Pride,
what's good? Tamar Buchanan, what's
good? Rudy Gentry 9603, what's adding
family?
The Vault, I see you. Bell, what's good?
Looney Wave, what's good? Larry Morgan,
I said that already. First generation
millionaire, what's good?
Steve O, what's good?
Mason to wavy, what's good?
Yoshi, what's good, family?
There you go. OAI 1339, what's good?
Marcus Watson, thank you for the super
chat, fam.
The concept, what's good, fam. Ashley,
what's good, love?
>> She said, "Every black person should
experience Martha's Vineyard in August."
Okay, may put that on my May put that on
my list for August for 2027.
Trap, holl at your boy King305. I see
you
bail. You know I know you, Shorty.
Sir James, uh 49 4579. What's good?
Tory Simmons, what's good?
Y'all be going fast. All Sports 2374,
what's good, fam?
What's up, Trap? Uh, Traders Armor, I
see you. Thank you, fam. Chopper Fellas,
I see you.
Horus Mo, I see you.
Aura F AR LLC. I see you, Mr. VIP. I see
you, fam.
All right. My eyes hurt now.
All right. Wealthy building bear, I see
you.
All right. My eyes hurt. Going too fast.
Interesting.
All right, man. We got a good show ahead
of us today, man.
Man, I've been um
I've been getting up every day, bro.
I don't know, bro. I feel like
rejuvenated. You heard me? I've been
seeing that boy allergic to shirts and I
said you allergic to them shirts and
them stories. I see I see what we doing.
>> Nah, [laughter] this when I'm working
out. And it ain't even be weightlifting.
It be jogging.
>> Yeah.
No, I ain't mad at it.
>> I've been jogging, bro.
I've been on it, dog. I ain't going to
lie. Like, nobody can't watch that and
not like, yo, let me do a sit up, a
push-up, run outside, a walk. You can't
not like you got to be an imbecile not
to. And shout out to all the imbeciles.
But you see this boy out there working
out and you just like every day like
really eating a burger. That's what we
doing.
>> Ride a bike or something. I see people
hitting me up now. They be like tagging
me. They be like, "Trap, I'm with you."
>> That's what I'm saying.
>> Kind of like I started a whole little
thing like you like, "Thrap I'm with
you, bro." Like people at least like
five people a day, I like they post cuz
they'll tag me. They like they jogging
or something. You know what I'm saying?
>> I even saw George on the treadmill this
morning.
>> Salute to George on that drink.
>> He need it.
>> Yeah.
>> Need say hitting the mountain this
weekend. I was like, "All right, let's
>> I go with him. I go with him."
>> I think the same one we got lost on,
too. That's why I'm staying on the path.
[laughter]
>> Bro, we got we was following the signs
and everything. Had to We got on the
other side. Had to take the Uber back.
>> No, I'm [laughter]
>> We had to take a Uber back. Bro, it was
crazy. I'm staying on the path
[laughter] this time. You hear me? But
it ain't never like three miles though,
so like a mile and a half up. But now
I'm about to graduate cuz now I'mma do
I'mma run a mile and a half up. I'mma
coast my way down, take a little
breather, and run it back
>> with the vest.
>> That's I'm about to graduate.
>> About to gra I'mma do it a couple times
without the vest.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Cuz the joints
>> then I'm going to do it with the vest
cuz then that that vest going to add a
little more cuz that vest like 20
pounds.
>> You know what I'm saying? I want kind of
lock in before
that winter time come for that. I
probably can make it all the way to like
October probably.
>> Yeah. I probably could bang it out all
the way to October. You know what I'm
saying? And if I could do it
at least, I don't know, three times a
week, three, four times a week.
>> Mhm.
>> N you hit that mountain. That's a
spiritual.
>> And bro, I be It's crazy part, bro. Like
the last couple days, bro. Like
I've been getting up like my whoop I've
been doing good with my whoop. Like my
whoop been green.
I've been resting, but I I've been I've
been I gotta start going to bed a little
bit earlier because I've been averaging
like 11:30, 12.
>> Yeah,
>> I think maybe Monday I did 1:00.
Maybe Sunday or Monday I did one. Maybe
Sunday I did like one o'clock.
>> But like I've been getting like that if
I won't push it to like 10,
>> bro.
I've been trying that therapist. If I
can get If I can get that 10:00,
that 10 to 6:30 10:30 11.
If I can get that 10:30 to 6:30, bro,
[sighs]
that's the hand I want right there.
>> Yeah. Now, that's
>> I won't get it. I won't get without
depriving myself to sleep. So, I won't
get it by saying, "All right, let's go
to sleep earlier so I can get it." You
know what I'm saying? Cuz now, if I get
up at 6:30 and I only got 5 hours of
sleep, I'm like, "Damn, I could have."
>> Right.
>> Right. So I won't get it from like I
won't get that 10 o'clock. I got my
little black mask.
>> You got to do brown noise, white noise,
anything like that or just silence?
>> No, bro. I go I need silence.
>> Yeah, I can't
>> blackout curtains.
>> I can't.
>> Black in the crib.
[snorts and groaning]
>> And once I and I'm starting to put the
phone like,
you know what I'm saying? So I I was
thinking about something too, bro. Like
I wanted to say this was in my head. I
want to say this
the same
I wrote this I said the um
the same freedom
like the same so in a situation like if
you don't have discipline
the same freedom you fight for becomes
the same freedom that destroys you
if you don't have discipline
right so the same freedom you fight for
is the same freedom that destroys you in
the s the The reason why you I say that
is because like
the nose that you get when you don't
have freedom seem like punishment,
but the nose that you have to impose
when you have freedom becomes
protection.
You feel what I'm saying? So like the
nose when you don't have the freedom,
the nose that you give me like
punishment like no. You like damn bro.
But when you got the freedom, nobody can
tell you no. So now you have to
self-impose the nos. Yeah.
>> So they can protect you.
>> That's protect.
>> You know what I'm saying?
>> So it's like, all right. Like what do I
like what are the things you got to
start like what are the things you got
to start telling yourself no to?
Like and you got to start and you got to
start telling yourself no like to
protect you from you.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Right. And a lot of times we don't be
knowing like we don't be being like as
human beings bro like just realistically
bro like we don't really be being real
with oursel
a lot of self a lot of time we give
ourselves too much grace
right we give ourselves too much grace
like we think like man I'mma just do
that it's all right
>> just one time
>> I'mma just do that I ain't really
tripping
>> I deserve it
>> you know what I'm saying and you do it
and then that lead that starts to that
ignites the endorphin because what you
what I learned about you know just us as
being human beings like
a simple thing done once gets easier to
do the second time.
You know what I'm saying? Like it gets
easier to do it the second time you did
it the first time. So it's easy to miss
the first day of workout. Now the second
day is like ah yep
right like
if you and and the thing about the thing
about life and and who we are as as
human beings some people like I got an
addicted spirit no you just don't like
to tell yourself no
>> right um
man sometimes you can be
um yearning for
whatever
And it's your ability to like
endure that
that that builds you and not lie to
yourself about it. Like a lot of times
like we'll do something like let's say
like
you working out good, you working out
and you like dog I really want to eat
that.
>> Yeah.
instead of just saying like, "Nah, I
really want to eat that, but I'm not
going to eat it." That's better than
lying to yourself like, "Man, I don't
really want it. I don't really want it.
I No. No. Cuz now you trying to suppress
a feeling. Don't suppress it. Feel it."
>> Yep.
>> And still tell yourself, "No."
>> You know what I'm saying?
>> And I think we got to learn that on our
wealth building journey because as you
become traders,
um, [laughter]
Um uh my my sister Terica just texted
me. Um as traders,
especially as traders,
your ability to make the money is one
thing. That's one battle.
Your ability to tell yourself, "No, I'm
not going to trade." is another battle.
But your biggest battle becomes telling
yourself, "I'm not about to put all this
money in that trade."
So, somebody called me this weekend, uh,
a trader. They DM' me and he was like,
"Say, bro, I I need to call you, dog."
Like, was that talked to me? He said,
"Say, bro, you're the only person I know
that put this type of money in trades.
I've seen you win a lot. I've seen you
take some losses. I'm about to make my
first trade that I'm gonna put $250,000
in.
But I don't I don't know how to
emotionally go about it. So I said,
"Man, you know what? Here go my number,
bro. Call me." So he called me. He said,
"Say, bro, like I just" He said, "First,
I got to give you a credit, my nigga."
He was like,
"I don't know how you do it." [laughter]
He was like, "Bro, you consistently be
putting big money in these trades
and like win lose or draw, you show up."
And he was like, "Bro, like I you the
you the you're the only person that I
know that do it, so I just got I just
need to have like 20 minutes with you."
I'm like, "All right, I got you. What's
up?" He's like, "Here's the trade I want
to get in."
I put my biggest my biggest I put in the
trade was like 6075,000.
He said when I put the 75,000 in, I
doubled it. So I saw the 75 become 150.
He was like, "Bro, I got it." He was
like, "So now I won't go 250." I said,
"That's a big jump, right?" I said, "Why
not go from 75 to 100?
Scale your way into bigger trades."
He was like, "Yeah, you right.
Here's the play I want to get in." I
said, "Okay."
He said, "But I'm kind of nervous." He
said, "Cuz I see a few things ain't
right." I said, "Let me tell you
something." I said, "I want I want I
want to tell you something. The minute I
say the minute you don't see a couple
things right, that mean you know for a
fact that the greed is fueling this
decision. I said I'm going to give you
an example.
I made my million dollar trade.
I said I made my million dollar trade
cuz everything lined up the way I wanted
it. We was in a hell of a bull market in
memory. Pulled back by off the 20. I was
able to get in. I said they had earnings
the next day. I mean, I said, "Mu had
earnest."
It popped. I said, "Not three days
later, it fell." I said, "But here's the
thing."
I felt incredibly good about that trade.
Like, I ain't second guess it. I didn't
[gasps]
I was like, "Bro, when I dropped the M
in that I sat back like, yo,
like I felt good about it. It It did
what I wanted it to do, so I made room
for it."
>> Mhm. I said in this situation you
secondguessing it and you haph like you
know that it's not the trade that you
really want to do that to. I say now
mind you
it could go right it could go wrong but
the worst thing can happen in this
situation is it go wrong and the trade
didn't look like you wanted it to look.
I said, "So even if the trade look like
you wanted to look and you get in it and
go wrong, you're not going to feel bad.
You just unlock the new level because
you know what you're looking for and the
market went against you." That happens
all the time. But knowing you shouldn't
have put in, I didn't you don't feel
100% about the trade and you want to put
it in, that's a 100% fact that you being
greedy because you think I said because
the first thing you told me was if you
put 250 in, you can flip it to 100. I
mean, you can flip it to a half a
million. When you leave with that,
that's greed. Cuz
my goal wasn't to take the million and
then turn it into a million. My goal was
I won't put a million in a trade, but my
setup looks good.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> He was like, damn, that's good, Trap.
I was like, so just scale down to 100.
Don't force the 250. I said, cuz the
worst thing that can happen to you, bro.
I said, I know. I said, one of the worst
feelings you can feel when you go big
like that is when you get a drawback
first day of the trade.
I said, "Bro, when you go big like that,
you get drawback day one. You in draw
down,
it's a different feeling, bro."
>> Cussing everybody out.
>> You know what I'm saying? It's going up
and down, you ain't tripping. But when
you hit it, hit the button, draw down.
Oh, that's a that's devastating.
I said, "So, bro, I say, so I I'll
wait." He hit me up this morning. He
said, "Bro, you saved my life." He said,
"Bro, [clears throat] if I would have
got on that trade Monday,
15% draw down."
I said, "That's why you need people to
talk to [laughter] cuz sometimes you
need a set of eyes."
>> How long he been trading?
>> Me?
>> Him?
>> He ain't trading for a minute.
>> Okay.
>> He been He ain't new to it. He been
training for a minute. the the amount
>> that he was stepping into a new so he
been having a really good year. So he
had a good first part of the year
>> like he was kind of like me actually. He
had got into oil stocks a little bit
before me
>> in the beginning of the year and then
like he didn't jump into the memory
trade like me but I think his biggest
trade of the year was like he caught
Microsoft at the bottom right. He had
put like 75k in it jump back to to a
buck 50. So he was like I'm ready. So I
think he told me like he up a half a
million this year. You know what I'm
saying? And so I'm like, yeah. I'm like,
bro, like I was like, and you don't want
to be up at half a million. You put 250
in a trade and one trade don't go right,
you don't give him half of it back.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. I'm like, you put a 100red in it.
You set your stop loss at 30%. You lose
30% of you ain't tripping. You going to
change your attitude. You put 250 in
there, cuz you going to try to want, you
won't get that 250 up. You don't want,
you know what I'm saying? So he was
like, he hit me the day. He was like,
"Say, bro, man, you saved my life, cuz
it's a different game up here. It's a
different game of death.
It's a It's a completely different game
of death. It's a game like I think I
posted today. Like I haven't posted in a
while. Not because I I've been having so
I was like I posted on it today. I think
the draw down today gave me like a
$300,000 loss. $290,000 or something
like that. 291.
But I've been having wins since then. I
don't had like $50,000 days, $60,000
days. I even had like $200,000 days. But
I wasn't like and and I don't want to
sound arrogant. I like I like uh what
you call it um
I like shock like shocking. Like I like
uh
when you post something is shocking like
oh you know what I'm saying? I like that
shock there like like I want you to see
be like a damn
>> like good or bad like Yeah. And like I
want you to be like, "Damn." Like even
the day when I posted it was down 291. I
was like, "You hit that like damn
down 291." That's going to shock you.
That's going that's going to stop you.
Like damn. Woo. Look, hold on. Here's
the crazy part. When you post those big
numbers, my DM and my text go crazy
like, "Yo, what's going with your man?
Shock. It's a shocker. [laughter]
>> I'm trying to get in. It's a shocker. Y
my drone be dust.
>> Yeah, it's a shocker. That
>> That's why I do it." So like I don't
like I bro I be have I bro since I've
lost the $300,000 bro I've had a $50,000
day $60,000 day $80,000 a day. We did
that in 2023 and 2024.
Not being arrogant
just saying like we that that don't
shock my audience.
>> Used to it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> That shocked my audience in 2023. That
shocked my audience and 2024 we amped it
up 200,000
300,000. And they saw that, right? So if
I post a $50,000 win, it's like,
[laughter] right,
>> damn trap.
>> We done seen that.
>> You heard it vicariously through.
[laughter]
>> I post a $50 like damn trap, you fell
off cuz
>> you done size down cuz what's going on?
[laughter]
>> Was that it cuz
>> right that is.
[laughter]
You feel what I'm saying? Like I post a
50 grand like damn cuz 50 that's all you
got for come on now
getting small [laughter]
account getting small what's up
>> you got to get back to the fundamentals
you better go back to buying whole
account
[laughter]
>> so I even post I ain't really post a
little and I I don't mean that to take
away from nobody thing but it's like if
I post a 50,000 or $20,000. They gonna
be like,
"Nah, you good." Trap
>> swipe.
>> You good over there.
>> So, I be want to hit him with that.
200 burger is another say, "All
right, now
>> right."
>> Oh, he back.
>> There you go.
>> Either way.
>> Okay.
>> Upside or downside.
>> So, today I I haven't had a big day like
this in a long time. All my even my
losses been like ever since the 350 day
the losses because it was like all right
100,000 they didn't see me lose 100,000
before that ain't gonna make them be
like damn they like a trap that ain't
nothing you all right I post that 290
he's like hey
what's going on trap that's what I like
that's what I like in their spirit it's
kind of like LeBron like when LeBron if
LeBron do like Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> You know if LeBron do like 20 and 10,
you looking at Brown like, "Bro, fell
off."
>> 20 and 20. 20 and
>> Anybody else do that?
>> Anybody else do 20 and 10? They on
sports in the top five.
Brian do 20 and 10. Like, oh man,
>> he falling off.
>> Is this your king?
>> You [laughter] know,
LeBron average for the year was 2018 and
five. Oh, he fell off. is going
to the Hall of Fame.
>> Hall of Fame MVP.
>> Yeah,
>> you got second in the MVP runner up.
>> So that's kind of wild, man. So today
was my first like big L in a while. So I
had to post plus my page was like kind
of been tripping. But yeah, my my squad
know like you know we've been having
some win like especially the whole run
up we had with memory like the last week
and something but I couldn't never get
that that you know what I'm saying? I
ain't never get that to post
[clears throat] it. I was like, I'm
close, but it ain't there. It's like
125,
165. My page going to be like,
that ain't nothing.
Ain't nothing. Somebody else post it.
It's like, dog, I post it like they on
your heels, trap.
>> They come to get trapped. Somebody else
post that 125, 150.
I post it.
>> You ain't there. You like, "Oh, they the
next back black pants."
>> Man, you ain't did nothing. You fell
[laughter] off trap. That ain't the
tribe I'm used to.
[laughter]
Anyway, let's get to it, man. Let's get
to it. All right. So, here we go, man.
I am a certified Wall Street trapper.
I'm confident in my ability to make
great investments. The stock market is a
machine that prints money and I'm more
than capable of operating this machine.
I don't know what I free myself, but my
family will eat for a lifetime based on
the information I apply today. I'm a
money maker and a wealth builder. Today,
I break all the chains that anchor me to
that poverty mindset. My ancestors will
smile now because I've turned our last
name into asset. My family's purchasing
power will increase indefinitely. Today,
I make the declaration that no longer
will I be a slave to money. No longer
will a generation behind me and Harry
lack. No longer will I submit the sell
of my time for money. I am a first
generation millionaire. I am the
architect of my family's legacy. I am a
certified Wall Street trapper. And Wall
Street looks like us now. Let's go, man.
[music]
>> [music]
>> My daughter, Jose, man, my daughter
came, bro, my daughter been home from um
Bro, my daughter been home from freaking
St. Thomas.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Man, that little gremlin ain't called me
yet, bro. [laughter]
You hear me?
When she start school the next she
missed the first day.
>> Ah
she missed the first day. I was telling
my dog Greedy that he like man you know
she done got back. She she talking to
her friends.
>> I ain't she she ain't seen him in a
month right
>> you know she like newoo now she b she
balling. She got a you know
>> I said don't say that no more.
[laughter]
>> She said what's that?
>> Yeah man. I um Yeah man. Say, "Bro, I'm
not lie, bro." Like, I had such a good
time with my baby, dog. Like,
and and let me shout out my cousin El
and my cousin Ken.
>> Mhm.
>> We had a good time, man. Having the
girls out there, man.
Um, seeing them out there, you know,
man, it was good, man. I'm not going to
lie, bro. Like,
I love family, bro.
>> Yeah.
>> You know what I'm saying, bro? Like I
love family, dog.
>> And definitely we good, you know, help
them put a smile on their face by taking
them on a trip.
>> I love family, dog. Ain't nothing like
some family cuz
So anyway, let's get let's get it, man.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go on the
chart right quick. Uh I want to show
y'all a little something.
Uh
there we go.
Um,
am I going webbby? I'm going audio 3.
Show more entertainment room. There go.
Yeah, man. I I really love um
I don't know what ain't clicking for me.
Other
I really love rocking out with my
family, man.
At first, I didn't think Elise was
there. I was like, I ain't see I ain't
see She must have been taking the
pictures.
>> So, Elise be chilling, man. Like,
>> Elise be chilling, dog. And like that's
my shorty, man. Like,
>> bro, like let me tell you something,
bro. Like,
bro, like
I love Elise in a whole another way,
dog.
>> Yeah.
>> Like,
you know, it just And I say this a hund
times, bro. like she one of them ones I
like
ain't too many she probably the only
person in this world outside of Leah
that I'll say like bro I lay my life on
the line for
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> outside of Leah like I'll lay my life on
the line cuz I know like
I got her set up and I know one thing
like she'll take care of my short.
>> Mhm.
>> You know what I'm saying? Like man she
helped me down when I was chosen dog.
like that that like
[laughter]
that that different dog like
like I'll leave my life on the line for
short dog like real talk you know what
I'm saying like cuz I know one thing
like
you know like
I don't even know it dog Like
>> words can't describe
>> it can't describe how I feel about her.
>> Yeah.
>> It it just can't it can't describe it.
Uh like
>> how I feel about her. Like
cuz you don't know what it's like, bro.
Like when you
bro when you lonely cuz
like and you just in them moments where
you don't think nobody care about you.
You know what I'm saying? Like,
>> you don't think nobody care about you.
You don't think nobody love you.
And
you watching people get mail.
You watching people get
money.
You watching people get pictures.
And weeks go by, you can't call nobody.
Nobody not really answering the phone
like that. So you just really like in
hustle mode.
And then you know
one month mail call
Leon. How
[clears throat] 416448.
You got mail.
You get that letter
>> Elise Hob
>> and see we would never know that that
feeling that feel like that lifeline
that
that level of gratitude
brit
is
that is unexplainable bro
that is unexplainable
when you when you think the world forgot
about you, bro.
And it ain't nobody fault. It's your
fault that you in here. So, you not even
blaming nobody.
But just to know like
y'all still love me.
You feel what I'm saying? Like just to
know like, man, y'all still love me.
And I ain't going to lie, my uncle wrote
me here and there. You know what I'm
saying? He came see me. You know what
I'm saying? But like to know that like
and she was so young.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> You got to remember I'm in prison at 16.
So she 13, 14.
>> Yeah. So for her to have the
mama, write my c and maybe my uncle was
like, man, write your cousin. You know,
I ain't taking away from nothing from my
uncle and my aunt. Maybe they was like,
"Hey, write your cousin."
>> Yeah.
>> You know what I'm saying? But it's like
you in that bro, and you fighting
for your life every day.
Not may may not literally fighting for
your life, but you fighting for your
sanity,
right? You fighting for your sanity,
bro. You know, I'm 16, bro.
You know, I'm watching dudes get, you
know, the homosexual activity. I'm
watching dudes get jugged up. I'm around
dudes with life. I'm I'm around all kind
of stuff. Every time I hit a bar, hit
boom. I might jump. You know what I'm
saying? In my mind, I'm I'm on the
outside. I'm like, you know what I'm
saying? Whatever. But in the inside, I'm
like, God, like you like I don't know.
The female I'm dealing with. I'm in here
cuz I let this female set me up. Should
I should have shot the dude? Should I
not have shot the dude? You know, I got
so much stuff going in my head that I'm
living with. I'm mad at people and I'm
just like, bro, like you
you just think the world forgot about
you, cuz that's all I can say. Like,
you, bro. And you you figuring it out in
that joint.
You know, you you know you ain't really
getting no bread like that. And it ain't
it ain't nobody fault.
Who is this calling me? Man, don't call
me right now.
Deny this call. How do I deny that call?
Hang up.
Get off my line.
And so you just
So this could be the sign for somebody.
You got somebody in there. Go ahead.
Send them a letter, an email.
>> A call. You don't know how much and how
like that one letter would last me to
the next letter.
See when she sent some pictures in it
like she sending me pictures of her
going to like on vacate like when she
became like a woman a developing woman
like she got like 1920 and she had her
friends like she just had the
wherewithal to send me pictures of her
friends knowing damn well I'm about to
say cut hook that one up. [laughter]
Right. Right.
And she rocking me so much. She like,
"All right."
You know what I'm saying? Here go.
>> That's crazy.
>> You know what I'm saying, bro? Like, so
like that type of And when I come home,
I remember her. I got her picture of me
coming home. I got my dreads. She's so
small. And we like, "Come on, let's go
to the club." She got my glasses on in
the club cuz now I'm outside. And all I
want to do is show her big c. I got you.
That's all I want to show her. Big C
home. I got you. So she would come to
New Orleans, bro. Whatever she wanted to
do, man. Come on, cuz I got you.
>> Yeah, she got, you know, Gucci glasses
on, you know, she got all my on,
you know, whatever I got here, cuz. So I
just always wanted to show her that like
I got you, bro. So like
that's my baby, man. That's all I can
say here. Like that's my heart, man.
Like
one of the reason why this can't fail
for me is my daughter versus the
mission. I know God that got that God
got me on it. My daughter and then
Elise.
Cuz even in the mission when I first
started, I said cuz man quit your job
man.
Man quit your job man. She was like
what? Like what you doing? I'm like man
I'm doing this man. I don't really know
how this going to look, but quit your
job. Come work with me.
And bro, like at first she was fighting,
but she would call me pissed off at that
job like, "Bro, I told you quit that
I got you."
And I remember telling her like, "I
probably can't pay you what they paying
you, but I promise you ain't going to
never go broke.
I promise you your lights ain't going to
be out.
I promise you always have food on that
table.
And if you help me build it, I promise
I'm going to make you a millionaire,
too.
And bro, she just
she quit her job on that promise.
And when I say it ain't nothing she
ain't try to figure out. And I don't
y'all don't even know how hard I'd be on
her.
>> Can imagine,
>> bro, I'd be hard on her.
>> I [laughter] can imagine.
>> You got to treat this like it's
yours,
What?
>> She take it like a G. You got to treat
this like it's yours cuz
I won't hear that.
If something happened to me, you got to
run it. Can you run this? Like I'm on
her. Y'all don't see that.
Y'all don't see the fussing that she got
to endure at 12:00 at night.
Why this happen? Why this happen? Why
you ain't on that? You supposed to know
that.
You supposed to understand this. You
supposed to understand that. If I fall,
what happened?
You going to go back to work or you
going to build this Why you ain't
learning what I'm doing? Like I'm Y'all
don't see that.
You know what I'm saying? Like y'all
Y'all don't see that.
Y'all don't see them. Like I be on her,
bro. You know what I'm saying? So
it's my baby, man. Anyway, let's get to
it, man. Let's get on this chart. Let's
get to it.
All right. Let's let me see. Am I chart
on there? All right. Cool. Cool. Cool.
Cool. All right. Cool. Shorty, I love
you, baby. [laughter] She probably like,
why you putting my business out there
like that? I probably will get a text in
a minute.
All right. So, here we go. Let's talk
about this company right here, STX. So,
a lot of people So, I'm in this play.
Um, the play had got all the way up to
came up. Where my shirt at? Go that
girl.
So, we know Memory has been having a a
cool little time last couple week. We've
been ride we've been rocking out with it
for a while. Um, just want to show y'all
a little something. And today you going
to see me show you the money. Like all
our plays was up really really good.
Today just wiped us out. [laughter]
I thought we was on green. We was on
green and everything. Like we was like,
"Oh, it's popping." and talk about today
wipe out wipe out and we couldn't do
nothing about it cuz it wipe us out like
from a overnight wipe out. So we woke up
this morning wipe out like damn bro. So
So here's what happened. So let's just
talk about it right quick. So if you
look at SCX here I'm going to show
youall something that's really critical
right here. Um, if you look at it here,
you can see that this is major key
level, right? Major key level on on on
this over here. But if you look real
close,
you actually have a support level right
here.
That's pivotal. Now, notice and it's
dropping down now cuz overnight is at
8.89. So, it's probably going to fall a
little more. It's probably going to give
up. If we look at it right now, the
20day is at 8.91 is at 8.89. So right
now it's currently under the 20 just
looking at the overnight market.
All right. So let's look at it. So let's
look at kind of what happened today. So
you had this move here from yesterday.
We had we got above our key area which
was actually really good momentum. And
if you put the fib on it,
move it up.
If you put the fib on it, it's right
where it need to be at. So when the fib
is right above that 618. So yesterday's
uh yesterday's price action put it above
the 0.5 and above the 618 which tells us
that the momentum had shifted to bullish
right. So remember on that type of draw
down on on a fib when you going from
swing high to swing low once you cross
that 50 then get above that 618 that
mean the likelihood of that retracement
is really really like weak right because
now it's saying that sellers have
stepped in
like of course you can some can always
push something down but that tells like
yo sellers have stepped in it's above
the 618 so now it's actually gone
against the downward trend it's
reclaimed some forward me some forward
moving structural points, right? So,
that was really good. That was really
good to see. We like it. We we we
appreciate that. Now, what happens is
what really made it really good because
it got above that 963. Well, trap. Why
was the 963 important? Well, because
inside of your key level,
you had these structural points. I want
to use this and I'm going to show you
how to market. If you able to see this
going to be good. So you got a So you
got it here. You got it here. You got
here and you got here. So you got it
drops come back drop
right in here. So that became a key area
for it to get across. Right. It kept
getting hit at what?
It kept getting hit at what? 936.
Right. So that's a support inside of a
key area. So now it looks like what's
called a supply shelf, right? Which
means every time it gets there, market
starts to do what? Sell off or buy
sellers start to what? Absorb buying
orders, right? So that becomes a supply
shelf. Why? Because it's a support level
inside of a key area. Does that make
sense to everybody? Right? It's a
support area inside of a key area. Now
if I take all that away,
it also looks like this.
You feel me?
All right. So
everything inside of here
is just wide consolidation.
Everything inside of there is why
consolidation because buyers keep trying
to get it above that and then sellers
keep saying nah I'm straight on that cuz
[snorts] so what happens is yesterday
well Friday it broke it. We got in it
Friday.
Once it broke that support area, it got
we got in it. And then not only did it
break that support area, it also closed
above the key area which was 965. So for
me, I'm like, "Oh, that's good." Cuz
what happens then? We also get above our
20. We also get above our 50. Our 20 and
our 50 stacked on top of each other. To
me, this is a good trade to get in. Now,
here's something I kept saying in the
group, though.
Don't go too big because that 10y year
is elevated.
So I keep trying to tell us that because
I don't care how good the setup looks,
that 10 year is above 4.5.
It's now above 4.6 and today it's above
4.7.
Now we getting into some dangerous
waters because once it gets to five, we
could probably see the market just bleed
out like tremendously. So, every I think
for the last two weeks I've been saying,
"Yo, we still got that elevated tenure.
We got that elevated tenure, y'all. We
got that elevated tenure. Make sure you
size down. Make sure you size down.
Don't be greedy. If it don't look
perfect, don't get in it." Because what
happens is with an elevated tenure, you
can just wake up one morning, the market
just sold off big. And you don't know
why. Because it don't have to be no big
news. It's just it's elevated. And when
the bond market sells off, that mean we
have a debt problem. That mean we have a
bond problem. When you got a bond
problem, that's going to mess with the
whole market, right? And so remember the
thing I always tell y'all, the stock
market is just the makeup that the bond
market wears,
right? But people don't be paying
attention to the bond market until it
start flashing. So I be trying to get us
to pay attention to that all the time.
So today that bond market flash 47
18.
That's enough. You know what I'm saying?
And then you had a 20-year bond that
increase, a 10-year bond that increase,
a 30-year bond increase, and then bond
yields increased all across the world.
They increase in China, they increase in
Japan, they increase in Tokyo, they
increasing a lot. So now we have a bond
market that's saying that the whole
world is kind of in trouble right now.
And I think that everybody is being
impacted [clears throat] by this war.
the impacts of this oil not being able
to go through this straight is causing
um it's impacting everywhere around the
world.
It's just impacting everything. And so
that's what happened man. So you know
again we had an overnight gap down gap
down from
let's see we gapped down from 1,12 we
gapped down to
closed the day at 900 no closed the day
at 8.98 now we at about 887 so
just pay attention to that so I'll look
at another one but also you got to be
willing to see like where is the market
kind of like seeing some type of
strength and so one of the things we
talk about on Patreon is where is
strength being shown at strength is
being shown in healthcare strength is
being shown in energy strength is being
shown in real estate strength is being
shown in
uh consumer defense and companies like
um Eli Liy um
he got the same tabs open as last week.
What? How many tabs you want me to have
open? Like I [laughter]
look at the same 50, 60, 70 companies,
family. Many tabs you want me to have
open. I don't I don't look at porn, bro.
[laughter]
I don't look at none of that, bro. I
look at the same thing over and over
again, bro. Charts all day, every day.
Um, so again, we seeing strength and
right here. So, we've been in this Eli
Liy play for a while. we kind of getting
chopped up, but you know, it's been
pretty good. Um, one of the companies
that's doing really good right now is
Coca-Cola hitting alltime highs again.
Coca-Cola,
Pepsi, companies like that. And so
that's what you should look at when Now,
there's two things you can look at
um in these type of markets.
Um,
you can be looking at
discounts in companies that's selling
off but holding strength
or so like Coca-Cola is holding
strength.
I don't know why I'm taking a little
long to load. Um, but Coca-Cola is
holding strength. There we go. So, you
could look at Coke. You could look at it
and see what you got. Your 20 going up.
You got your 50 going up. 200. So that's
kind of good. Coca-Cola sawing strength.
You got a all-time high at about what?
90 91.
Yep. 90. Current stock is 8906. Remember
Coca-Cola don't move big. So you can see
stocks like Coke, you can see stocks
like Pepsi,
they holding strength.
So, that's kind of where you're going to
be at. Now, if you're looking for,
don't get me wrong, tech can be great,
but remember those other stocks going to
move a little bit slower.
But if you just looking for, hey, let me
stay here. Now, the bad part about that
is
anytime tech starts to move, then these
companies start to slow down because
people will rotate back into tech. You
know what I'm saying? So, you just kind
of gotta
uh
Pepsi not doing that good, but they come
off the bottom. So, yeah, they under the
200 day, which right? They coming up.
Pep need to be doing better. [laughter]
But y'all get what I'm saying.
So, let's look at Costco.
I don't know why my stuff taking a
little long to load up. Is it raining
outside or something?
[snorts]
Huh? Like really slow?
Super duper slow.
Um
I don't know what the hell going on.
You see? Try to do it again.
Maybe try to change that thing out, bro.
Anyway, y'all get what I'm saying.
I ain't about to keep going back and
forth. That That's it for All right,
let's move on, man. Oh, let's show the
people the bread, man.
Got to get that fixed, bro. Like, can't
keep having the same problem, bro. Over
and over and over again. Like, got to
get that fixed. Spending too much money
here for that not to.
It don't have nothing to do with the
cashier, the browser history. You just
be having slow internet sometime.
We got to get that fixed, bro.
Can't keep having that same situation.
So So
as you can see,
Yeah. Gutter moving like AOL over here,
bro.
I know I paid too much money for that.
You hear me?
Uh,
back to back to dollar. Big buildings
have that problem because of structure.
Yeah, we got a lot of stuff in here
though. We got frequency enhancers, too,
Queen. Trust me.
Um,
yep. Might got to go with Starlink, man.
Canceling the AT&T. We canceling AT&T.
We canceling all of them. Bernard, why
you ain't never say let's go Starlink,
bro?
We going Starlink, bro. They about to
lose our business, bro. Internet too
slow, bro.
You know what I'm saying? Internet too
slow. All right.
All right. So, as you can see, like in a
lot of plays that we down on, we just
gave up. That was the gap down. So, ABV,
that one did good for us. But look at
the AEHeR play. We was up about 19 grand
on that play. Lost n took 19 grand down
2,000. That's a huge swing on that play.
You know what I'm saying? So again, we
was doing really good on that play. See
why RX play was doing a little bit. Our
Dell play we got in a couple weeks ago.
You can see it was up a thousand. We was
up almost $1,200. That swung different.
I was down $1,000 on a drawing play
overnight. And it when I say it was
overnight, like it was down opening
bail. Like opening bail, it was down.
So, like it wound up ending the day in
the same place. Um, you need more
bandwidth and repeaters trap. We got a
ton of bandwidth and we got a ton of
repeaters. But everything y'all are
saying, trust me, everything y'all
saying, we 10x that, bro. I promise you.
>> We appreciate y'all. [laughter]
>> Trust me.
>> When the roof is messing up, now you
need the shingles, but you need to
>> trust me. Everything y'all saying, we we
10x that.
>> We appreciate Um, and you can see that
um the drawing play we was up, we was
down $1,000, we lost $12,000 and then it
pivoted. So that really stuck us hard.
Um, the FT& play
um, that one was down, so we got some
play on that. Goldman Sachs, that one
was down. The HP play, we was up like
right at $4,000. Swiped out, took all
that away. Let's go a little further.
All right. So then the Eli Liy play, as
y'all can see that play, so we that one
kind of like coming back for us. Uh the
Morgan Stanley play, well, it never
shook all the way back. Microsoft play
not doing what it's supposed to. MU
play, that one hit us really hard. We we
was up and then that one like swung
really hard on us. The SNDK play did
stay strong though, so I'm not mad at
that one. But look how big it was. We
was up big on that play. We still up
18,000. We was probably up like 50
something,000. So, you know what I'm
saying? Go a little further.
And so there go our two STX plays.
Uh just wiped everything out. You see we
down 43. Wiped us out on that one. The
other one 66. Wiped us out on that one.
and then the TRV play that we had in. So
everything we had was up doing pretty
good and then we just got that that gap
down today just punched us in the face
hard. So it's part of the game. I ain't
really tripping but that's why we had
the big L today cuz a lot of stuff was
positive went negative
from the overnight gap down. So but I do
want you to look at it from a
perspective like I got over a hundred
$200,000 in some of these plays. So it
ain't that bad. So let's go a little
further, man. Yeah, bro. Getting cooked
for sure. I [laughter]
Huh. Yeah. I ain't I ain't going to run
from it. Getting cooked for sure. But
the thing about it is
even with a stop loss, a overnight gap
down don't do you nothing cuz you gonna
just get gapped out when the bell open
in the morning. So
huh.
Yeah. So yeah.
Uh, why was CR YX a play? What was the I
would have to go back in my notebook and
see it. Uh, but yeah, so that was our
place, man. But I'm, you know, the crazy
part is
let me see. And that's just way too high
for a lot of us to be trapped.
I don't know. I don't know what that
mean. Um,
somebody say trap man, my check engine
light is on.
Nah, somebody say, "Man, I thought I was
the only one getting hurt." Bane, what's
happening, family? There go my dog Bane,
man. [laughter]
Uh, a stop loss don't do nothing for
you. So, you know what a stop loss would
have did for me this morning on that.
I would have still been down that much
on all them plays on a stop loss because
those plays pretty much didn't lose too
much more. like where they opened at
they only they fell a little bit more.
So I said I lost 290 one by the day's
end. If id have cut it at a if I have
cut the stop this morning I probably
lost 260.
The 30 that I lost by the closing bell
wasn't going to make or break me.
You know I woke up this morning in the
red from that gap down. So yeah.
So anyway, yeah. Uh, are these companies
you wouldn't mind holding for the long
term? I don't trade a company that I
wouldn't hold.
U Trap is showing us how to stay even
emotion. Yeah. I don't be really
tripping, man. I'm all right with that.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like I woke up this
morning, that gap down had me down 260.
So
got to remember we only was down what
1.3%
by days in.
Um, I had to leave the Patreon because I
couldn't afford some of the big plays,
man. For sure, bro. I mean, we do all
size plays, but I just trace the
winners, bro. Like, I go after big dogs.
I go after big dogs.
You know what I'm saying? I want you to
build your way up. Long as you still in
the game, dog, that's what matter to me.
Yep. Trap. You saw the gap down coming.
You saw it in the live you did Friday,
100%.
There are option plays for under a
grand. We do a lot of option plays under
a grand. But here's the thing, bro.
I'll tell you something, bro. And here's
what I like to tell people, bro.
Go where your tribe at, bro.
Go where your tribe at, bro. Like, I
have I feel no kind of way. Go find your
tribe, bro. Long as you still in the
game, I love it. Find your tribe,
family. That's That's how I feel about
it, bro. Like, find your tribe, bro. You
know what I'm saying? [laughter]
Find your tribe, bro. You know what I'm
saying? I just I like to see people
making life changing money. You know
what I'm saying? And this is my tribe.
That is, bro. You know what I'm saying?
That's all I say people, bro. Like, find
your tribe. As long as you still in the
game,
I love it. You know what I'm saying,
[laughter]
family? Nikki. All right, let's go a
little further, man.
>> [panting]
[music]
>> showing the Wall Street Trapper
Patreon.
>> Mhm. Somebody said something that was
good.
It said stop loss would have made that a
realized loss instead of G time. There
you go.
Mhm.
Shout out my girl Ashley. No love. Shout
out my dog Davon.
All right, let's go a little further.
Let's get into the buy and hold.
What's good, Shorty?
All right, here's our buy and hold, man.
So, we still up 31% year to date. Um, we
sitting on $34,000 in cash.
Um,
EM is doing good. Fix, bro. If I could
get some option plays for this this that
company, Fix Comfort Systems,
I promise y'all that would be my one.
But they option chain is so trash. Now,
here's one that turned around. It
one turned around the beginning of the
year was popping middle of the year
start falling off and now it's turned
around since this war has increased.
That's it.
That's it. I like that. MU has actually
done me good. MU was down.
It was up to 150. It got all the way
down to 75,000. Now's at 104,000. So,
shout out to MU. Nvidia still holding
strong. He just never broke out for me.
PWR went negative, is back positive. STX
has just always be family. TPL just been
whooping my butt since the beginning.
And Walmart been navigating between
being up 2,000 and down a thousand since
the day we had it. [laughter]
So there you go, man. Come join the
Patreon, man. Y'all know how we get
down, man. I actually um
I hate when good companies have trash
option chains. Pascal for sure. If y'all
go look at that FIX options chain, it's
so disappointing and so discouraging. No
volume, nowhere on the chain. I'm
talking about not as a day trade, not as
a two-eek trade. The option chain is
really, really, really, really sickening
on there. Um, and let's get into it. Um,
I won't get into this information, but I
do want to say something. I don't have a
uh chart for this or nothing for this,
but I want to say this to everybody on
here. Um,
starting in December, the market start
to do 23 hours a day. So, I think it's
going to go from 9:30 to
and then go back from four and then go
back from nine to four something like
that and man oh there go right there I
didn't I did have it the NASDAQ is
preparing to keep the US stock market
open for 5 days for nearly 23 hours a
day 5 days a week beginning December 626
proposed schedule will run from 900 p.m.
through Sunday 9 8:00 p.m. Friday with a
1-hour daily pause, a new overnight
session from 9 to 4:00 a.m.
will join NASDAQ's sending existing
trading hours. The expansion aims to
meet rising global demand for US stocks,
but the launch stills require SEC
approval and industry system readiness.
Regular trading hours from 9:30 a.m. to
400 p.m. Eastern time will remain
unchanged. I'mma be real with y'all,
bro. Like, I hate this in every which
way.
I hate this in every which way possible.
And the reason why I hate it is because
you will not be able to go to sleep.
Like, you can go to sleep not knowing
that all right, whatever happened
overnight, I'm good. But now like you're
not going to be able to go to sleep
because now you know people like your
positions going to be getting wrecked.
And the reason why this is happening,
bro, is because I'm going to be real
with you. Wall Street is now competing
with the gambling market.
I ain't gonna lie. I wish somebody with
some common sense say, "Nah, we got
futures for that."
We got futures for that.
We got futures market for that. If you
want to trade them late hours, go trade
the futures market, bro. Like this gonna
be so or this going to be and this is
going to hurt so many like people
because
people going to become gamblers.
It's going to be the destruction bro
man. Man, Emit, appreciate the super
chat. We trap on green days as well as
red DS. We not shook. If you knew that,
then you know that's a fact. Shout out
to my dog Emit, man. Shout out to my guy
Emit, man. You heard me. [laughter]
Uh,
>> I think that might be our largest one
time super chat, too.
>> Probably.
>> Mhm.
>> Um,
I don't like this, man. I'm not going to
lie. And I'm not saying I don't like it
from a trading perspective.
I just don't like it from a perspective
of
like
they 100% doing this to hurt the retail
trader.
This is designed if they go to these
hours. This is designed to hurt the
retail trader
because they not going to be playing.
They not going to have nothing but
algorithms doing that all night. They
not going to be up doing that. That's
gonna be number algorithm trading all
night.
This game wasn't designed. This is This
is the This is the big dog saying, "How
do we make more money?
How do we make more money?
How do we make more money in this game
without putting in more time?" All they
going to do is let's real alos
algorithmic trading all night.
And now you up all night watching your
stop loss. You up all night trying to
enter a trade at 2 o'clock in the
morning.
Who Who's trading at 4:00 in the
morning?
So again, I'm not saying it's fair at
all. I'm just saying you got to be able
to see the play before it's You got to
be able to see the play.
And you know it's coming because
all they going to do is lobby for it.
And lobby just mean whoever try to stop
it, they're going to throw them 100
grand, 150 grand because they know they
going to make millions on the other
side. You know who going to make money?
All of the hedge funds. But most
importantly, your Goldman Sachs,
your every or your your commission
companies who getting paid from you
trading
it like, "All right, y'all want to
gamble? All right, we going we going to
put it on your front door."
All right, Robin Hood, y'all want to put
all that on up? We going to put this on
the front door.
And so what I will say is
what I will say is
somebody say nah fam that's what bots
are for. All right see how that work for
you.
What I will say is
find your rules stick.
Somebody said, "Bro, getting a margin
call at 3 p.m. going to be crazy."
That's a fact. So, I just want everybody
to just be prepared for what's coming
cuz we ain't going We It's here. So,
once they introduce it,
Once they introduce it,
I'm about to hire somebody on the
Patreon that's gonna come on.
>> That's what I'm about to say. Is there a
theory or a thesis that you will have in
this to win?
I know you don't like it, but
>> I gotta Everybody gonna have to adjust,
bro.
Ain't no one person going to have to
adjust. Everybody gonna have to adjust,
bro.
Everybody going to have to adjust, bro.
Everybody have to adjust. Even they
going to have to adjust. But they
putting things in place now.
Everybody going to have to adjust, bro.
>> Cuz you going to have to understand like
what's going on at night time. You have
to understand how the market's moving.
Is they going to have a lot of V? You
want Everybody gonna have to adjust,
bro.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's go a little further, man. All
right. P now. Prosper later. Jenz, this
goes right into it. Jeffrey Nola, man.
Appreciate the super chat, family. Let
me I I didn't salute you, man. Jeffrey
Nola, thank you. Trap real is real.
Salute. Jeffrey Nola, appreciate the
super chat, fam. $100 super chat. Thank
you, brother. I appreciate it. Um,
what I will say is, right, and this goes
right into it, right, Gen Z is moving
from stocks to sports betting and wealth
plans. Um, sport betting um, is
increasingly competing with traditional
investing for young Americans attention.
With more than a quarter of Gen Z
investors saying they see gambling on
sports as part of their long-term
financial strategy according to a survey
by personal finance platform Betterment.
See what I'm saying?
The market is saying, "All right, y'all
want to gamble? I'mma give you something
to gamble with.
That's all that is.
That's what that is.
That is we not about to let Sports Bank
get all that money. Let's get some of
that money.
That's what that's all that is, bro. We
not about to let Sports Better get all
that money.
Will the stop loss last 24 hours, man? I
don't know, bro.
We all got to We all got to [laughter]
We all got to see what's going to be
like. We all got to see what it's going
to be like, man. So, let's go a little
further, man. I'mma just say this, and
there's nothing against my sport betting
people. There's nothing against all
that.
The stock market was the greatest show
on earth at one time.
Yeah, you shorty say, "Hey, most
gamblers are not on the market anyway."
True, but a gambler gonna be a gambler.
And here's what the market will do. The
market will 100%
increase
They want some of that money. If they
can get a percentage of it, 10%, 5%,
whatever percentage of that money they
can get, they want it. And that's all
I'm saying. I just don't want us to fall
into that. But it is what it is. Let's
go a little further, man.
All right. So, it says that I'm trying
to see something right quick, Jose.
Yeah, I think my page shaking back a
little bit, Jose. Okay.
Bro, I'mma tell y'all something, bro.
I've been fighting Instagram bullies
for two and a half months.
I'm talking about literally like Well,
two months.
>> Since overseas,
>> since the week I got back from Italy.
>> And when I say I've been fighting them
cuz
>> And they've been whooping on you. But
I've been fighting cuz I ain't a
lay. [laughter]
>> I know. I know.
>> I'm talking about every post cuz like
and I'm the person that don't reach
inside my rolodex, bro. I've been so
deep in my rolodex, guys.
>> I'm talking about people in private
equity, people that I know that hey,
[clears throat] I probably got like
eight people at Meta
>> phone numbers and emails
every time a post go here. [laughter]
Look, look, hit the screenshot.
>> They attacking, they attacking, they
attacking, they attacking, they
attacking.
>> And I know they like, "God, I'm like,
bro, can't y'all see it's an attack on
me?" Like, every post been getting flag
flag.
So,
>> and not one got an answer,
>> huh?
>> And not one person got an answer or they
got multiple answers.
>> Well, they just been they see it's
unusual, but I guess they don't know how
to figure it out yet. They haven't
figured out how to figure it out yet.
Um,
but man, it's been it's been
um
we've been fighting it. We've been
fighting it and and we getting a little
progress cuz now my post starting to go
a little bit. I started getting a little
bit of range, a little bit back. You
know what I'm saying? Like I was
averaging 25, bro. I was averaging 25 to
28 million views a month
>> on my page. In the month of June, we did
seven posts that did a million plus
views.
>> In the month of June, in the month of
June, we did seven posts in June alone
that did 1.2 to 1.7 million views.
We was on fire
slapping them.
>> I said, "Jose is up." I said, "Jose, we
gonna get to two million." We going to
get to 2 million people on this page by
the end of the year
>> cuz we had it cooking.
>> You know what I'm saying? But
>> school cuz now we focusing on YouTube a
little more.
>> But just know like I'm going tell y'all
like I told I'm telling my team I ain't
paying for it.
>> I have never been extorted in the
street.
>> I will not be extorted on no social
media platform by no nerd.
Is what it is. So, we just been
fighting, dog. You know what I'm saying?
[laughter]
We been fighting cuz And at first I was
like pissed off. Then I started having
fun with it. Like, come on. You fight, I
fight.
>> You got to play the game.
>> You fight, I fight.
You fight, I fight. Let's rock. You get
them all flagged. I got enough people.
I'mma keep on sending them to They going
to keep getting unfl flagged. You know
what I'm saying? Let's go.
>> Cuz I promise you, it could be worse. So
this is a good
>> because that's how it go. Once you get
flagged enough, they take your page
down. So every time you flag it, I send
it to one of my people.
Unfl flag it. Un flag. Unfl flag it.
Every time you reject the appeal, I
appeal it back. I appeal it. So now we
you you flag it and I'mma appeal it.
Let's go. Let's go. You flag, I appeal.
One of us going to get tired. Hot
potato. [laughter]
Somebody going to get tired. Somebody
gonna say, "Bro, it ain't worth it, bro.
Let's go somewhere else, bro." He got
somebody. Let's go somewhere else. He
got somebody. He found somebody.
>> It's you.
>> He found somebody. We got to go
somewhere else. He done found the plug.
All right. So,
[laughter and clears throat]
they don't know how much in the trenches
you be for your own stuff. [laughter]
>> No, I don't trust nobody with it. I got
>> I got I'm fighting cuz I one I refuse to
pay somebody.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> I refuse to pay somebody cuz once here's
I'm going to tell you something my
people told me in the street dog. It
says once you pay draft once,
you will forever be a drafter.
Right? So once you pay draft once, you
are known as, "Oh, he going to kick
out."
So anytime I'm hurting,
what's up? Let me get it out with you.
You got to pay draft. So I kept that
mindset. I'm like, bro, if I pay
somebody one time, man, I'm know isn't
they going to throw it in a circle? Hey,
you can go hit his page. You go hit his
page. you. He going to pay you the four,
five grand. He going to get it back. He
going to get Man, I'm not paying
nothing.
Dollar bill.
>> Then they just came up with the metal
one advanced.
>> Man, I'm not paying nothing.
>> 49 a month. Like, hey,
>> not paying nothing cuz every time you
flag it, I'm I got like eight people
number and eight people email. Every
time you flag, I send the email to all
eight of them. All of them get the
screenshot and the post and your name.
>> Hey, this one, this one, this one, this
one. you getting this.
>> I just get the email that say it's
clear. It's clear. It's clear.
I might don't got the range like I was
having before, but my post start to go.
And that's I I like that.
I like that. I like that. Anyway, let's
go a little further. All right. So, the
S&P is calm under the surface, but
chaotic under the hood. Uh more S&P
companies are now moving against the
index at any point since 1990. a surge
sign of surging under the service
volatility. On July 31st, 121 stocks
showed negative beta, right? Showed
negative beta reflecting extreme um
dispersion as investors.
Investors crowded to AI winners like
Micron, Sandis, and non AI names lags.
Bears
as we go a little further. Hold on,
y'all.
Because I know
where is I.
All right. So, here we go. So,
bear seat echoes of 2021's.com unwind,
but ever coach Julian Emmanuel argues
that less a bubble warn and more proof
that the market has split into two
tribes, AI stocks versus everything
else. Jose, let's put a poll inside of
there.
Um,
where do people land at? Do they land on
the AI style socks or the non AI?
What it what is it?
And so also I want you to understand
something. A company with a beta of one
or more means that it moves a lot with
the market. So it has a lot of movement.
A company that has a negative beta means
it doesn't move as much as the market.
Meaning it's not volatile. So this is
like a SanDisk or MU if you look at the
beta on that is going to probably be one
or above. That's why they move so much.
Then you have the companies with
negative beta and that's companies that
don't move as much. They're not as
volatile as that.
So, let me let me ask y'all
which ones are y'all with? Y'all are
with the more more volatile stocks are
more with the negative beta stocks.
And I'm not just going to say AI, but
some people say I want the AI. That's a
fact.
Ah, V Nomad say um I'm a hybrid approach
trap. I like that.
I like that
at range. Okay,
both. I like that. I like that. I like
that. All right, let's go a little
further. The S&P is calm on the surface,
but chaotic under the hood. The number
of stocks traded neg and there we go.
So, the number of stocks traded with
negative beta hits a new high. So,
that's showing us that like the market
is So, here's what I'm going to tell
y'all right here. Watch when I say this.
Watch when I say this. Watch when I say
this.
Watch when I say this.
Negative beta stocks going to be where
the money at, but they not going to be
popular.
Look at it. A number of stocks trading
with negative beta to the S&P hits a
alltime high.
So, if you can go find stocks with a
with a one or lower, and I'm not even
saying negative. I'm saying you can go
find some stocks with a one or lower,
you're going to say, "Hey, damn. These
suckers is outperforming the market."
There you go. Somebody hit it. Sh been
shorted. Take risk off the table. I see.
There you go, brother. There you go,
brother. Also, I want to talk about one
stock that I've been talking about for
years now. Me and Black Robin Hood don't
got no beef, but I gotta call that
sucker out right here.
Gotta call that sucker out right here.
Let me say this again. Me and that man
don't got no beef. But I'mma call that
sucker out right here.
Two years ago, I said,
"Leave Nike alone."
Two years ago, I said, "Leave Nike
alone." I said, "Hey, the stock is
getting whipped by brands like Hoka,
brands like um
what's the other shoe brand?"
Who? But Deckers is under Hoka is under
Deckers. Um what's the other shoe brand,
man?
Cool.
No, it's another with a big platform.
Hoka. I forgot to how to pronounce. Huh?
Who? Sketchers. There you go. Hoka.
Sketchers and some of the other on
cloud. Yep. Some of them other brands.
And so what' you say? I didn't hear. My
bad. Yeah. Yeah. So yeah. Yeah. So uh
and I said, man, these companies are
outpacing Nike because Nike used to be a
runner shoe and then there was a
athletic shoe. Brooks, all of these
shoes. And I said, when I look at the
earnings call, like these stocks like
taking a lot of market share from Nike
and then Nike is not getting like the
basketball
like a
athlete have having a shoe doesn't do
what it used to do.
Does that make sense? Like we don't care
about Katie having a shoe. We could care
less. Maybe the basketball person, you
know, they care, but like the basketball
community cares, but like like when Mike
dropped the shoe, we all cared about
Mike dropping the shoe.
Like we wanted Mike with, right? Even
with LeBron, like when Brown was
dropping, when Kobe was dropping, like
we didn't care if I wasn't a baller cuz
we lighted the shoe. Now we don't care.
We don't care. And so I remember that's
when I said that about Nike, that sucker
said Trap don't know what the hell he
talking about. He made a post, you and I
think the next three days Nike like
popped up for a minute and that
fell back down to the ground. That
was at $100 then. That is worth $39
right now. And I just want to tell that
sucker. You owe me a freaking apology,
bro.
You feel me? I just want to tell you
that, bro. Like you owe me apology, bro.
You owe me a man. Trap was right on that
one, bro. You guys ain't much, but you
owe me a challenge. Right on out,
[laughter]
>> dog. I'm looking at the notes. I'm
talking about episode 57 was the first
time you was like,
>> episode 57.
>> 57. This is August 23rd, 20, 2023.
That's the first. Cuz before he was
like, "Oh, what's up, Ernest?" And then
he was like, "Oh, no. We on a losing
streak." He was like, "Nah, get out."
>> I [laughter] was like, "Get out of
there." Episode 57.
I was like, "Hey, get out of there."
3,000 people in the chat.
>> 3,000. And they like, "Jose, what you
doing?" I'm looking up notes. I'm trying
to go.
>> There you go. Yeah, bro. I I was like,
"Bro, get out of there." And that that
joker said, "Man, y'all better stop
listening to Trap." And I we we on way
better terms now. We way on better terms
now. I just want to tell that sucker
that he owed me a positive post.
The sucker owed me a positive post.
>> Was on tour. This was building a trap
house. Huh?
>> Building a trap house. That was the name
of the episode.
>> Yeah, but Nike is in the trash.
It was a hundred and something dollar.
And here's the crazy part. I don't see
it coming back.
I don't see it coming back. I don't know
how
you would have to bring in a new CEO
that revamps
how that brand is distributed.
Right. Again, you're you you lost the
running you lost the running world to
Hoka and Yeah. You you lost the running
world to them. Brooks, Hoka. Like I run
at Hokas.
You know what I'm saying? man. Like I
run a mountain in them and them suckers
light
that soul absorb that cushion.
Yeah. So
I don't know how they get that brand
back.
You need That's That has to be a hell of
a CEO
to come in. They got to kind of do what
Louis Vuitton did. They got to come in
and bring a popular name in. They can't
go the old way. You got to come in and
bring a popular name in and let them
like redesign and revamp
that whole shoe catalog.
You lost clothing to Lulu Lemon.
Lulu took the at leisure. And another
thing that's killing you now is like
with the women. So like a woman can have
a nice a pretty face and a nice body and
work out. She can start at leisure line.
You feel what I'm saying? Like if a
woman has a pretty face, a nice body,
and she work out consistently, she can
she can she can drop a at leisure line
and she can serve her fan base that. And
the reason being is because we live in a
world now where people want to be cool.
Like ain't nobody wor about like people
want to wear at leisure clothes all day,
bro. I wear jogging pants all day, cuz
>> everywhere grocery store,
>> bro, I be having jogging pants on or
little joggers, bro. I be want to wear
that all the time, bro. I got I be like
I don't want to put no jeans on, bro. I
be like, I'm not wearing them. I'm
wearing cargo pants and joggers, bro. I
do not want to wear I be like, damn,
[clears throat] I got all them jeans.
I'm not wearing none of them jeans. I
always want to get
>> feeling heavy when you
>> I got so many Listen, I got so many pair
of like Amiri jeans and and and and Tom
Ford jeans.
I don't want to wear them. They sitting
there in the closet. I'm like I see them
there be like
I don't want to wear them, bro. Give me
some Caros. Give me some joggers.
I'm good. I do not want to wear them
jeans, man. Yeah, they need a They need
a heavy revamp.
Somebody
[laughter]
Somebody said, "What I need pockets
for?" Cuz she took everything.
Oh, that's it, bro. Yeah, I I'm tell I
I'mma be I at least got 50 to 60 pair of
jeans, bro.
That I just I look at them be like, "Why
do I got these jeans in my closet, bro?"
>> Nah, you different on that one. Golly.
>> I got like 50 or 60 pair of jeans, bro.
I'm just be looking at them like, "Yep,
I'm not ever wearing them again."
>> Sets of five probably look exactly
alike.
>> But it look good. [laughter]
>> Black, but it's just like the black
>> different color blues. black, gray, got
a couple tan pair,
>> couple green pair. I just brown. I'm
looking at I'm like, "Y'all ain't never
coming on."
>> In the winter, I'm just going thermos
and joggers.
>> I'm going put the thermal put thermos.
I'm still not putting you on.
>> Ask me try to buy me something. I like
don't those look like the same.
>> Yeah, I'm not doing that, man.
>> The car goes going to get some play.
>> But the jeans, you get no play, brother.
You get no you get zero play. I just go
a little further. Let's go a little
further. All right. S&P draw down
levels. Now, this is important. Watch
this. How often is the S&P in various
draw downs? So, watch this. 40% or
worse, 3.1% of trading days. 30% or
worse, 7.2. 20% or worse, 20.9 10% or
worse, 40.9 5% or worse, 55% of the
time. So you can expect a 5% draw down a
lot. The average draw down in the market
is 10%.
The average markdown in the market is
10%.
Somebody say something, man. The older
you get, you just want comfort. I think
I'm in that age of 44
where I just want comfort.
That's all I want, man. I want to look
good. That's why I'm working out a lot.
Even when I work out, bro. Like, how old
are you, Rob? 40. So, I'm 44. I don't
even want to lift that heavy weight no
more.
>> Mhm.
>> I put the 225 on, I'm like, yep, this
good. I put the 260 on, I was like, this
probably my max right here.
>> I'm like, I don't even want this no
more. Like just last before 45, I was
like, yo, I got to go get that 300. I'm
like, bro, I could care less about 300,
bro.
>> What they call a It's like ego lift.
What they call that? It's not ego
lifting is when you like trying to do it
for the video for the gram.
>> Nah, cuz you can ego lift with Junior
Partner.
>> Oh yeah, that's true too.
>> Yeah, you can eagle lift with Junior
Partner. He live 305. I'm going 306.
>> Almost killing yourself. Your blood
vessel.
>> They got to call the ambulance.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like I'm at like
all right, let me get to like I'm at
225. I can hit that 10 times. 250 260 is
kind of like the if I hit 275 I'm like
bro like that's enough. I just want any
get it off me. Yeah. Yeah. I I can hit
265 right now like four or five times.
I'm like, bro, this is good. I could
just if I get to 250, I can just rep out
the 250 like five sets of eight or
something like that, bro. I don't even
want to lift all that, bro. I won't I'm
44, bro. I just want to have good
stamina. I want to be in shape. I I
don't want to be nowhere close. Nothing
against nobody. I don't want to be
nowhere close to the Dad B community.
You know what I'm saying? I'm doing my
legs so I don't look crazy. That's what
I want to do, bro. That way my my shirts
can fit me good and I can have my I can
I can not wear my shirt and be like, you
know what? I'm comfortable in this. I'm
good.
>> Mhm.
>> I don't got even I don't even got to
suck in. I'm okay. I'm natural.
Let's go a little further, man.
>> Shout out to the people who still be
sucking in. And we see y'all out in
these streets. You be sucking in
>> slight. [laughter]
[clears throat]
>> You was sucking in on Martha Vineyard.
>> Slight.
>> You was sucking in on put You put that
shirt on. You like just a little chest
up. [screaming] Suck a little bit. Yo,
it's a lot of dudes who need to be
sucking in doing a lot of laughing
behind me. [laughter]
>> Hey, he don't like that. Hey, bro. One
thing about Jose, bro, he don't like to
be by himself.
>> You got to bring other people in. You
bring other people in for you. Here, you
laugh.
>> No, listen. This is my joke. They be
trying to throw a little They laughing a
little too hard.
>> No such thing as funny. If the joke
funny is funny.
>> Hey, no, no, no. That's that we good. We
good. But just know when it come back,
nobody don't care about it coming back.
Jose
come back. Nobody don't care about when
they come back. Let it come. We welcome
to come back. [laughter]
>> He always be when they come back.
>> But no, no, think about it like this.
You remember back in the schoolyard? No,
they clowning.
>> Jose, we 40. Listen, we clown.
[laughter]
Listen, we cl Oh, yeah. It got me
schoolyard. You clowning the dude who
who laughing but he got the run over
shoes. Oh, we about to light you up,
boy. Like, was you crazy? Some of y'all
need to No, me not.
>> Jose, we 40. Nobody cares about the
comeback at 40. It only hurts your
feelings when you young, Jose.
>> No, we do.
>> Jose,
>> it's your comedy all day.
>> Only you do.
>> You gonna keep it.
>> Only you do. That's why you be mad when
people laugh.
>> No, I ain't mad.
>> Yes, you do.
>> I love it.
>> No, you don't.
>> Yes, I do.
>> I promise you I love it.
>> You know why you don't? Cuz you telling
people for laughing too hard.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah.
>> That's how we know you don't.
>> No, but I do love it.
>> No, you don't.
>> I promise you I do. Because if somebody
laughing at me even I'm getting like,
"Oh, you got ah that is funny."
>> It adds on to the comedic joint. I could
re Oh, I love a good comedic.
The science of comedy. So yeah, they
could laugh all day. Just, you know,
it's coming back. You just open yourself
up. You making my point.
>> Oh yeah, but I still love it.
>> Flush, Jose, man.
I get flushed.
9:00.
God dang.
All right, let's go a little further,
man. Let's get it, man. Y'all know we
like to have fun and talk stocks, man.
All right, let's get a little further,
man. Now, this is interesting. The US
30-year levels hit all-time highs since
2007 as war in oil worries fester. Now,
this is where things get really, really,
really, really heavy at y'all because we
are now 6 months in on this joint,
right?
We are six months and we start saw this
what, February, right? We're six months
in on this and there has still been no
resolve.
There still has been no resolve. We've
like Trump has bombed these people to
smitherreens and they still not
complying.
Which tells us something we said from
the beginning is bro we should not be
over here.
But you know why we can't leave now? We
done spent so much money and now we egos
and attached
and now you threaten to bomb the other
country if they do a deal with them.
Bro, this is a war that should have been
avoided. We should not have been in this
war from day one. We let somebody buck
us up to get in this war and we fight.
We really fighting somebody else war
right now.
We are really and truly fighting
somebody else's war right now because
that ain't had nothing to do with us.
Our only beef with Iran has always been
y'all don't have y'all don't deserve to
have a nuclear bomb. That's Huh. That's
been that's been but that's been the
deal since what 92.
Yeah. That's supposed to be since 92.
Like this straight of her move stuff
that we got going on, bro. This don't
got, bro. We bro. So, here we are.
Here we are
again.
We feeling the inflation. We paying the
money.
And so then the thing about him is once
he do one thing, he double down. So look
what he does. Trump redraws the map. He
posted this on his thing. President
Trump's post an image claiming that the
straight up her moves is now new US
territory as US oil prices exting gains
toward $85. Bro, that ain't for us.
That ain't for us.
This is gaslighting at its finest. Now
he got away with the Gulf of America.
I don't know how, but he got away with
that.
It's on Google Maps. You can't put this
on.
You got away with the Gulf of America.
Even nobody even calls it that, but you
got away with it. But, bro, we don't own
that, bro.
And then people showing us that we don't
own that.
And at some point,
at some point,
um,
we I'mma say something, bro. We have the
potential to be in this joint for a
year.
And I'm going to be real with you.
This war is what's going to cause a
recession.
H.
Well, I don't agree with that.
True enough, you can't put in a new
president if you still at war. Well,
it's really hard. It's really hard. But
I do think that because now
his presidential uh acceptance rate
is has sunken. So at this point even the
people who rock with him like nah bro
you got to get out of here because
nothing that every you know how you make
people turn on you when people start
feeling it in their pocket.
Because here's the thing that people
don't understand.
There's a lot, and I'm saying this, and
don't don't beat me up behind this or
nothing. Even though a lot of like uh
Caucasian Americans voted for him, they
now looking at their wallet like, "Bro,
what's going on?"
You know what I'm saying? And even a lot
of the black and Spanish people who
voted for him, they like, "Hey, bro,
what's going on?"
Because the one thing that people
judge they vote by is how much money you
put in my pocket.
That's what people judge their votes on,
bro. At the end of the day, like, did
you affect my bank account? That's what
people want, bro. And right now,
you're hurting a lot of people's bank
account.
And I'm I'm not even talking about the
stock market. I'm talking about like
these gas prices. I'm talking about the
cost of inflation. I'm talking about
food going up, rent going up. All of
that's a byproduct of this, bro.
So,
somebody said, "Oh, well, voting or
nonvoting has a consequence." I'm not
disagreeing with that either.
I'm I'm not a gri I have zero sympathy
for folks that voted for this
administration. I don't know if I'm
asking for sympathy or not. I'm just
saying that like I'm talking so much
about the inflation and how it's
affecting
the, you know, the people. Um the number
one rule and and at some point maybe we
get out of this war and maybe we get out
of it and we got a new Federal Reserve
in play and and I'm only speculating
that this could last, but we not in it
for 6 months. And
with us being in it for 6 months and we
keep seeing the deal go back and forth,
back and forth, back and forth, back and
forth. Something has to give. And I said
this from the beginning. The new the new
head of regime over there, you killed
the people, daddy and the people,
brother.
At no point do I feel like I had nothing
to lose at this point.
Why would I give in?
So there you go. [snorts]
Let's go left her.
US oil reserves have hit its lowest
point since 1982. The US strategic
petroleum reserves held 293.4
million barrels, down about 5.3 barrels
in a week from 298.7
million. This is the lowest since
December 1982.
Now, this is important for America
because what happens is now we need
these to be back up as stuff starts to
happen.
Yep. Shazam X trap. I think this war is
going to fast track the recession that
was already coming. I agree with you
100%.
Somebody say voting ain't going to do is
fa I'm not here to debate how you feel
about that. I I don't like I'm not here
to debate how nobody feel about voting.
I really don't care if you're a
Republican or a Democrat. I don't be
caring, bro. Like I'll be honest with
you, bro. Like because I think that
you vote for who you feel
like you vote for. I think this world
has made I think we've now because
somebody don't agree with our religious
beliefs we be like I don't like that
person or somebody don't believe with
our political beliefs it's like oh I
don't like that person uh you may not be
agree with a person's sexual beliefs oh
I don't like that person I'm not like
that I'll be honest with you bro like I
was in prison I know some of my homies
that was like doing a homosexual thing
bro you still my dog that's your choice
I don't got nothing to do with that,
bro.
You're still my dog. I know people who
I'll be honest with you. I got I know
people who 100% like love Trump.
All right. That's your political views,
fam.
All right.
You know what I'm saying? Like I got
people who,
you know, long in my mind, long as you
a rapist, I can't get with you at all.
>> Right. Rapist or child molestation?
>> Child molest. I can't get with you at
all, bro. I think people who have
different political views than me makes
for great conversation.
>> Yep.
I think people who have different
religious belief than me makes for great
conversation.
>> Makes for great dialogue.
I
>> think it makes for great dialogue.
>> I think we got enough stuff in this
world to make us like not like pull us
apart
than looking for things that help us
move together.
And I think in this world we don't look
for we always look at stuff from one
side
our side and we like I'm standing on
business. But when you stand on a
business like that you don't give
yourself opportunity to learn.
You don't give yourself opportunity to
learn. And I think one of the things
that we all lack is a thorough
understanding
of
like why people think the way they
think. And I like to understand people.
I like to understand people. I like to
understand
I like to understand, you know, like,
damn, why you think like that? How did
you come up with that concept? Where did
that come from? Where did that
where did that start from?
>> Yep. I think one of the things that
could go down to Jose is like so like
when you go to court like and let's said
like I remember me going to court
like I remember going to court and I
remember my aunt telling the judge like
when I was young my my aunt telling a
judge like
you know my grandmother passed and my
mom went to prison and I remember my
aunt Shirley George she was like
he just ain't had nobody to lead him,
right?
And I remember her talking to the judge
about my circumstances on, you know,
just the life I was living and how that
happened. And the judge had compassion
for me. And I shot a man, bro.
And you make it look at it like,
damn, he still gave you 10 years, but he
could have gave me 35.
You feel what I'm saying? So like un
like his understanding of
I can I can understand what happened.
I bet.
And I think for us, bro, like we don't
never like we be so good on like
standing on what we I'm standing on what
I believe and I ain't budging.
That doesn't leave room for compromise.
That doesn't leave room for
understanding. And it damn sure don't
leave room for growth.
>> Are you in?
>> And then we become we become we die on
our sword when we could have lived on a
different principle
because just cuz we don't agree don't
mean I got to change my belief. It just
mean damn I'm on here. I've never heard
that before.
You know what I'm saying? So, and I
think I think even like when people be
like with racism,
I remember being in prison, bro.
And I remember being in prison, bro, and
there were white people who were
officers at the prison.
They were like racist, right?
And I remember I got cool with this
white officer
and I asked her this question.
And I was like, man, why why so many of
you people really don't like black
people? And how is it that we got cool?
And she told me the most
I ain't going to say it was weird, but
she was just like,
for some of us, our first exposure to
black people are in this prison.
And I was like,
"You do know it's like 20 2004."
She was like, "Yeah, but we live in a
small country town.
It's all white people."
And so I was like, "Well, how did you
wind up?"
And she was like, "I went to college."
She wind up going to Magnes, which is
She was like, "I went to Magnes."
And she said, "I realized that black
people aren't what people told me."
Exposure
blew my mind, bro. Cuz we I'm like,
"Bro, it's no." I'm like, you know,
like, "Bro, why these people like it?"
And I was like, "Well, why?" She was
like, "Cuz they they haven't had
exposure." So only exposure they got is
with their mama and their dad. Because
mind you, the whole town works here. She
like, "They mama, they daddy come home
and they talking about black people."
Yada yada yada yada. So now when you
come to jail, you already have this idea
of black people.
She's like, "It took for me to go to
college. I went to Magnes State." And
she was like, "That changed my whole
idea."
I was like, "Damn." [clears throat]
So exposure
exposure changes
your view and your perspective
on everything. Anyway, let's go a little
further, man.
Let's go. All right. So, Wall Street is
Wall Street is record short the NASDAQ
100. Now, check this out. Let's go a
little further. So, watch this. The
index, which is the NASDAQ futures
position that hedge fund managers and
asset managers are actually short tech
stocks right now.
How's that? Let's go a little further.
[music]
First and foremost, I want to say salute
to the general Wall Street Trapper
himself. Shout out to Jose, shout out to
Rob, shout out to the whole Wall Street
Trapper crew. I'm Ron Johnson, also
known as Tenacious Pursuit in the
Patreon
trap. My question has to do with an
event that I'm putting together for
family members that I want to learn. I
want them to learn about financial
literacy. I want them to learn about
investing intelligently and navigating
their way through the stock market
successfully.
If you were teaching your family
members, which I'm sure you have, what
would be the three important things,
three most important things that you
would teach them first and foremost
before going any further? Also, trap, do
you have any pointers or tips on how I
could put my event together? I
appreciate you for taking my question.
Happy Trapping Tuesdays, everybody.
Salute.
>> Okay.
Uh,
dang. Somebody said trap. Salute to
action. Motivate trap. Imagine if you
never change your way of thinking. Damn.
Little trap and tools, man. Thank y'all,
man.
[laughter]
Trap, how do you find these fun facts,
bro? Yeah, I do a lot of Y'all don't
know though. I do a lot of research for
Trapping and Susie, y'all.
I do a lot of research for this show.
All right, research. Let's run this
question again. I heard part of it, but
I got off track. I got off track.
Three things. First and foremost, I want
to
say salute to the general Wall Street
Trapper himself. Shout out to Jose,
shout out to Rob, shout out to the whole
Wall Street Trapper crew. I'm Ron
Johnson, also known as Tenacious Pursuit
in the Patreon
trap. My question has to do with an
event that I'm putting together for
family members that I want to learn. I
want them to learn about financial
literacy. I want them to learn about
investing intelligently and navigating
their way through the stock market
successfully.
If you were teaching your family
members, which I'm sure you have, what
would be the three important things,
three most important things that you
would teach them first and foremost
before going any further? Also, trap, do
you have any pointers or tips on how I
could put my event together? I
appreciate you for taking my question.
Happy Trapping Tuesdays, everybody.
Salute.
>> Okay, good. So, first of all, salute to
you for putting the event together for
your family. I think that everybody
should do that. Um,
three things that I would
make like key factors would be uh,
money habits.
I would go right that would be one of
the things like how do we spend money,
how do we earn money, how do we save
money, how do we invest money. So money
habits would be the first thing. Um I
would I would I would do a lot of work
around. I would I would ask the tough
questions like I remember telling my
family
like when we was in the building I
remember saying like
this is so hard. So I got a cousin one
of my cousins she has
wiggles.
She has four kids and she work her butt
off, right, to provide for them and be
like, and I remember telling them, I was
like, I said, "This is going to be
tough, but I want y'all to I want y'all
to do this." I said, "Man, I want y'all
to look at your mama."
And I said, "I want to ask y'all a
question.
Y'all see how hard y'all mama work for
y'all?" They was like, "Yep." I was
like, "Y'all y'all" I'm like, "Do y'all
really see how hard she work for y'all?"
And they was like, "Yep, we do." Cuz I
said, "Now I'm gonna ask y'all a crazy
question.
Do y'all want that life? And they was
like, "Huh?" I was like, "Do you want to
be working that hard?" Cuz my cousin
work her butt off.
And it was like, "Nah."
And I remember asking her like,
"Tell them one thing that you did wrong
that you could be doing right that you
wish you would have did right." And man,
like she was almost in tears.
And I remember telling them like, "This
is why you got to learn how to invest
now.
This is why you got to learn how to
change your money habits now."
And I think that was like such a
I think that was such a mo it was such a
moment for them. You know what I'm
saying? cuz she was like, "Bro, like I
be working like my cousin be having
migraines
like cuz she just work work work work
work work work work." Now of course like
now like they all in college now so like
you know she get to take a deep breath
but she still got to provide for him but
she could take a deep breath now cuz she
done put four kids through you know high
school. So I could salute her for that.
All four of her kids graduated high
school. They all got their diploma and
one two all four of them tried college.
I think three of them still in college
right now. right? The three of them
still in college right now as a single
parent, bro. Like she did her job. You
know what I'm saying? So, I think one of
the things um would be
um making them have harsh conversations
about like what they do with their
money. Now,
um the next thing I would make them
focus on is the power of investing.
And then the third thing I would make
them focus on is
um I think money habits, the power of
investing and then I would kind of focus
on
like the I would make them understand
the difference between assets and
liabilities,
right? I think I would like lock in on
what that is. So that would be really
good. That would be really good. Um as
far as when it comes to how to put the
event together, it's not really hard,
bro. Like you know
what I did was I rented a house in
Orlando.
I will say like if you can get if you
have the if you have the wherewithal
if you have the wherewithal to like put
them in an environment where it's easy
to learn
like that's when it becomes dope. Like
we went to Orlando. We had this big
house. We had a chef. We had
it was easy to learn. And out of five
days, I took one day. I ain't trying to
make it a three-day event. I spent this
money on that. No. One day, y'all going
to learn how to invest. You're going to
learn about trading. You're going to
learn about business.
One whole day from what we did it from C
from like 10:00 in the morning to like
3:00 or 4 or something, right? 10 to 3,
10 to 4. That was it. I did my job. You
know what I'm saying? So, I think that's
it. And then after that, it's easier now
to have a meet. Now, I dropped the ball
because I went to building my business
and I just ain't had time to like keep
on doing it. You know what I'm saying?
Like, and then nobody really picked it
up, right? But again,
when you're the leader of it, you got to
kind of like
you got to kind of keep it up for a
little bit and then you can like take
your hands off it. But then I started
building my business out and I kind of
took my hands off it. You know what I'm
saying? So like it's easier to do the
Zoom call after you've done like some
inerson stuff with them and so they can
see it. So that's what I would say,
brother. Great job.
Great question. Let's go a little
further.
>> What if I told you one man fought
slavery?
What if I told you one man fought
>> Can we get a name first? count.
>> Mean you get the name cut.
>> What if I told you one man fought slave?
All right.
Perhaps the most strategic freedom
fighter you've never heard of. Born free
in 1804 Pennsylvania, he could have
lived a comfortable life, but he had a
bigger vision. He inherited his white
father's lumber business and transformed
it into an economic powerhouse with his
partner, Steven Smith. Together, they
built one of the largest lumber
operations in Pennsylvania. But they
didn't stop there. They expanded into
railroads, coal shipping, and real
estate. At his peak, Whipper was worth
over $100,000,
millions in today's money, making him
one of the richest black men in America.
But here's what made him dangerous. He
turned his entire business empire into a
weapon against slavery. His railroads,
they had specially designed freight cars
with hidden compartments. His lumber
yards, perfect hiding places for freedom
seekers. His ships, transported people
to safety under cover of commerce.
He estimated spending $1,000 every year,
a massive fortune at the time, directly
funding the Underground Railroad. That
meant bribing officials, paying for safe
houses, financing legal defenses, and
supporting abolitionist newspapers. And
he wasn't just moving people. He was
moving minds. In 1837, he published an
essay on non-violence that predated
Thorough's famous work by 12 Years. He
co-founded the American Moral Reform
Society, advocating for black economic
independence as the path to true
freedom. So why don't we know his name?
Because his story was too powerful. A
black man who proved that economic power
could dismantle oppression. While others
fought with speeches, he fought with
strategy, with infrastructure, with
cold, hard cash. You can see his legacy
in every black entrepreneur who builds
for purpose. In every community fund, in
every act of strategic generosity, he
wrote the blueprint for using wealth as
a tool for liberation.
I don't know his name. Jose,
what his name is, Jose?
What's his name?
Guess I had to chat his name, huh? Cut.
There it is.
William Whipper. [laughter] All right.
William Whipper was a successful black
businessman, lumber merchant,
um, and abolitionist in the 1800s. He
built wealth through lumber industry in
Pennsylvania. Uh, he used his money,
property. He used his money, property,
and transportation
connections to help people escape
slavery through the Underground
Railroad. Whipper also strongly promoted
education, entrepreneurship, and
economic independent as a tool for black
advancement. So, yes, this was the man
that helped Harriet Tubman.
This is the man that helped Harriet
Tubman, William Whipper. Now, this was
good because I ain't never heard of him
till we came up with it. Right? Think
about it. Lumber merchant, abolitionist.
He built wealth through lumber. And I'm
going to tell you something. The lumber
industry is not an easy industry to be
building wealth through. But it is
lucrative. Um, so yeah, man. Wilbur
Whipper. Let's put him on the list,
y'all. Let's put him on the list. Let's
go a little further.
Shout out to everybody in the Patreon.
Shout out to Trap. Shout out to Jose. We
super appreciate all the information
y'all be dropping all the gems. Um, so
yeah, I'm going to get straight to it.
Uh, I'm new to the, uh, investing
community. Uh, just investing period.
Um, I just started focusing on my buy
and hold this year. That's my primary
focus. And then I soon want to get into
swing trading. Now, um, the question I
have is, um, what are some trusted
companies that you would recommend when
it comes to trading? Like, uh, I've
heard of Wee Bull and a few others. I
just want to know like which ones do you
recommend and which ones are you using,
right? And then when it come to trading,
I'm understanding the terminology a
little bit better than the action,
right? So, how do I even put in a trade?
Right? Um, those are my main two
questions. what trusted companies are
you utilizing and or that you would
recommend and how do you what are the
steps to doing a trade? Like I said, I'm
familiar with the terminology, but I'm
not really uh familiar with the action
or the step by step to get this done.
Shout out to everybody in the Patreon.
Keep dropping gems. Keep uh motivating
the real. And shout out to you, Trap,
for breaking things down and simplifying
things in a a dope way, man. I really
salute. Wall Street Trapping. We
trapping.
Salute, brother. Salute, brother.
Salute, brother. Um,
some of the trusted companies that I use
is I use E Trade and I use Charles Swab.
But for somebody that's new, I'm not mad
at you using like Weeull.
I actually like Wee Bull more than I
like Robin Hood cuz Wee Bull not trying
to get you to gamble.
So I like Wee Bull and I I think you
could use Wee Bull for a minute. You
know what I'm saying? Like I think Wee
Bull is really good. So I would go for
if you knew I like Wee Bull. I like E
Trade. I like Charles Swab. Nothing
wrong with Fidelity. So I would think
that's the big four that you would go
with. Um when it comes to putting in a
trade,
I would tell you to take the Wall Street
Chapman. I mean, I would tell you to
take the uh
options master class, but if you want to
focus on buying hold, bro, like let's
focus on buying hold till we build you
up to become a trader. So, I like that.
But I I would definitely say woo Wee
Bull, man. Um I think Wee Bull is
probably the best
for beginners and I think Mumu is kind
of coming along. is evolving. But I
would say Wee Bowl I would go Weebull
out the gate if you're a beginner cuz
you can even learn how to trade on
Weeull. You know what I'm saying? So
yeah, and and I'm not even mad like if
you're a beginner, I'm not even mad at
you staying on Wee Bowl to learn how to
trade. You just get your trading view.
They have your charts up. I wouldn't be
mad at that either. I wouldn't be mad at
that either. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I like I
like that. I like that. Trade Station is
good. I think it's more evolved though.
But I think Wee Bowl would be a good
spot for him. So let's go a little
further.
Ah, here we go. So Nvidia sells chips to
these companies and these companies that
rent them. So Nvidia, Nvidia, I'm sorry,
builds the chips. um they deploy and
then they scale and then they get the
reoccurring revenue from uh coreweave
backlog at 104 billion NBIS the AI cloud
scale up and these the AI landlords but
um Irene and then APLD big tech needs
compute. So think about it like this.
Coreweave is the AI cloud leader. NBIS
is the AI cloud scaleup. Then Irene is
the AI compute plus data centers. And
then APLD is AI ready infrastructure. So
these companies are actually taking
um
um Nvidia like sells the chips and these
companies are you so that's just looking
at AI infrastructure per se. So, if you
have a long-term perspective, and I'm
not gonna lie, like I remember we was in
a group like and I remember saying like,
"Man, you gotta watch Core Weeave." And
I remember saying, "Core we now Irene I
wasn't really a fan of." But I remember
Cororee and APLD. I was like, "Hey, like
we got to watch these." Especially once
Nvidia put two billion into Core Weeave.
I was like, "Yeah, cuz Jensen ain't just
dropping no bread like that." But I
remember that now. I remember some
people in my in the Patreon was on
circle and I was like I don't know about
no circle y'all.
I was like I don't really know about
circle but I wasn't afraid of uh core
weave. So salute to all my people that
was rocking with core weave and ald for
the long term. Let's go a little further
Jose.
All right. Compute has become real
estate. Right. So think about something.
You hear about the picks and when you
hear people say the picks and shovels,
essentially what they saying is this.
During the gold rust, you had to have
companies that sold the picks and
shovels because the picks and shovels
became essential for for people to do
what?
Get gold.
That's why people when you hear people
say this is the picks and shovels of
this, this is the picks and shovels of
that. They're just saying that these are
the essential companies that are
necessary for
this thing to grow. So that's what that
means. So compute has become real
estate. So you think about compute, it's
think about it. Nvidia builds the GPUs,
cloud operators deploy, they rent the
compute, demand explodes, near-term
capacity gets tight. Then you have the
contractors. Well, the picks and shovels
which are necessary become companies
like who? Cooling and power. Why?
because you need cooling for it to work
and then you need networking so the the
information can get out and then you
need optics because that helps it travel
really fast and then you need memory
because AI is nothing without memory and
then at the memory you also need storage
why because the memory has to be stored
somewhere so you need cooling you need
networking you need optics you need
memory and you need storage those become
come picks and shovels because without
that AI can't move, right? So that's
what they mean when they say picks and
shovels. So I know a lot of people knew
and you over here you be like look at my
dog Nate man. What's up Nate? Bro, you
ladies, I don't know what, bro. But I
know you might be still out there. I
forgot where you at. You heard me? Yeah.
Ashley, no love. What's good? So that's
what they mean when they say the picks
and shovels. Um that's what they mean by
picks and shovels. They mean these are
the companies that are necessary for
this to go. Now, in anything that you
looking at, you can ask yourself this
question. What are the picks and shovels
for any industry that are necessary for
them to go? So, when you hear that term,
I know a lot of my people knew, they
were like, I don't know what picks and
shovels mean. That's what picks and
shovels mean. It just mean when the gold
rush was going on, nobody could dig gold
unless they had what? Picks and shovels
and wagons. And so, the picks and
shovels became essential. Now, speaking
of gold, Jose, did you know that Levi
Jean became a a dominant company in
America because they were the number one
gene used during the gold rush?
>> I had heard that on some documentary or
something like PBS
>> or whatever. That's dope though.
>> Levi jeans. Was that
>> That's dope.
>> Let's go further.
>> And I thought you was about to hit in
those jeans. You did
see the setup.
You got to You got to jiggle the handle.
[laughter]
>> Who would I be singing in those jeans to
Jose? You
>> That was the You was going about to say,
"Is that what happened when you were Jua
was on tour?" That was the the timing of
the Yep.
Yeah.
[laughter]
Tell me is there
no
okay
like who
like why would I be
[laughter]
go back to Marcus Vineyard bro go back
to Marcus Vineyard bro
>> did you say Marcus
>> I said go back to Marcus Marcus Vineyard
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> manual again.
I just fig it was a perfect segue.
That's how you That's normally when you
start shooting
and him for him to think that he that
was an alley for me.
It's the part that kills me
for him to say that's the perfect alley.
Sometimes I got to just question our
friendship, bro.
>> The back to back
>> and not even in a bad way. It just be
like
How did I get cool with a like
this? Y [laughter]
>> like God, what were you doing in my life
when you feel like I want him to be your
partner, dog? [laughter]
>> It's the balance. It's the other side.
>> Like what type of transition you had me
going on? Like this the one I need to be
your partner, girl.
Ah,
somebody say Jose still on that wine out
there from Marcus Vineyard. [laughter]
All right. So, Nvidia
as y and I always try to sell us this.
So, Nvidia is always buying positions in
companies.
That's what great companies do,
right? They buy positions in um other
companies. So, here's their position so
far. They have a 47% position in Intel.
They have a 33 pos% position in
um SpaceX worth $20 billion. They got
7.41%
position in Coreweave at $4.7 billion.
Uh y'all know I like this company, CHR.
They have a $3 billion stake in that.
Nokia, which was a sleeper. We've been
looking at that. I just never pulled the
trigger on it. Synopsis, uh, I've been
knew about that. They have a$2 billion
dollar
position in that. NBIS almost have a
half a percent position in that. And I
didn't know about this one about Gen.
They have about $14 million position in
that. So, I always say this when I'm
looking at Nvidia. They invest in the
future.
Y'all know I keep telling y'all
Nvidia invest in these companies because
he's smart. He never wants to be the
monopoly. He always wants to be the big
dog, but he never wants to be the
monopoly. He never wants to be the
monopoly. He He learning that from a lot
of other companies that can keep the DOJ
off him. He can be like, "Bro, how am I
the monopoly when I got I got money in
Intel?"
Not to mention he doing this big old,
you know, loan for them, too. So, yeah,
let's go a little further.
All right.
Oh, yeah. You can hear an apple on the
speaker. [laughter] That's why I laugh.
But hey, this a different show, bro.
That's cool. That's why I love it. I
love it.
Then they be in the chat talking about
what kind of apple. It's a Granny Smith.
Gold. So the green apple's not Granny
Smith's.
>> I don't know which one. I just know
>> Granny Smith or the red apples.
>> This ain't no Granny Smith.
The The red apples is Granny Smith's.
[laughter]
[screaming]
I love it. I love it.
You be standing on it. He's [laughter]
standing on it.
>> Huh? What's red?
>> See,
that's not what you said at first.
Wait. So now he Look, he switched sides
when he looked at it.
Man, Rob, you didn't do the homework.
>> I'm right. I'm wrong. Hold up. You
messed up on the Google. Did you mess
up? Oh, he got a VCR. That's why,
>> man. Flush ride, man.
Wait. Hold up. Hold up. Time out. Time
out.
My dog was going.
He was going against you. Then he looked
it up and said, "Nah, I'm jumping. I'm
jumping back."
>> That's right. The red is the honey
crisp.
That's right. The red is the honey crisp
apples. Y'all right. It could be It's
Granny Smith. Y'all got me. Y'all got
me,
>> man. Get out of here, bro.
I'm wrong. I'm wrong.
>> But no.
>> R.
>> Drop that in the chat. What that say?
Drop that in the chat.
>> He said the red is the greatest.
>> Let's go, Rob. Let's [screaming] go,
Ron. Unflush R. Bring it back. Roll it
back. Back. Roll it back. Throw it back.
Wait. Drop my dog with the bomb. Yo, I'm
not mad at you being right or wrong. I'm
mad at you switching sides three times.
Like that. Yeah, Rob. [screaming] Yeah,
Rob. Yeah, Rob.
[laughter] Yeah, Rob. No, cuz at first
he was like, "No, you wrong, Trap.
Granny Smith is the red. I know I'm not
tripping."
>> All right, let me see. I'm going go do
for myself. Somebody use chat. Google
something, bro.
>> Golly.
[laughter]
>> Let me see. Let me see.
>> No, don't send your link.
>> All right. So, all right.
>> What clause say?
>> It can be both.
All right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It said it
can be both. So, here's what it says. It
said Here's what it says. It says Granny
Smith can be both. Bright green and red.
The standard has bright green skin. But
you will see sun blush is what it's
called. Sun blush. Bright red Granny
Smith red apples.
All right.
All right. All right. All right. All
right. So, Rob, you ain't wrong. So,
it's a tie.
[laughter]
>> All right. It's a tie.
>> I ain't seen them get up out the chair
ever on.
>> So, that's what it says. That's what it
says. It says uh you can find both. It
says it can be Damn, I went off it.
Damn. Where the chat went at? So, it
does say that the standard is green, but
you can they do have sun blush red
Granny Smith apples.
>> All right. I'll take that.
>> I'll take that. I'll take that.
I'll take that.
I'll take that. Rob ain't Rob ain't Rob
ain't wrong.
Rob ain't wrong. I ain't wrong. But it
does says
green. It said green is a standard, but
you do find red. It's called sun blush.
Now, I don't know what sun blush is, but
it says sun blush,
but they red.
So, sunlush red is not green, Miss Abra.
Let's get your colors right now, Amy.
No, you get your colors right. Sunlush
red is what the chat said. It didn't say
sunlush green. It said sunlush red. I
know chat knows the difference between
green and red. I'm just saying get your
colors right. It said it didn't say
sunlush green. It said sunlush red.
>> I just going on record to say Jose
didn't argue about neither cuz I ain't
know.
>> I know I'm an apple person.
>> You know what I'm saying?
>> I like apples. I wasn't like if you say
it's red, I'm all right. I'm wrong.
>> Yeah.
>> But I know I've had a red one before.
But I know majority of the red comes in
the honey crisp color. The honey crisp
apple.
Yeah,
>> this is how we show, man. We do what we
want.
>> This is how we do.
>> All right, let's go further. So, Nvidia,
look at it, y'all. Check it out. Bank of
America sees Nvidia trading at a 50%
discount. I'm not mad at that. The stock
is up 17% year to date. My only thing
was I was mad that I didn't get it at
189. I was supposed to go leave option
when it hit the 200 day moving average.
I was supposed to go leave option. So,
here's my here's my free trade for
everybody in here. If Nvidia goes to 189
at the 200 day moving average, you buy
it, you go out 12 months. Yo,
that's trap recommendation.
>> You said 180.
>> 189.
189. That's what make this show good,
man. We not scripted, man. We go
everywhere, man. We go everywhere. All
right, let's go a little further.
Ah, so this is the one I want to show
y'all that I'm really good with. And we
kind of push for time here, but NLD. Now
watch this. This is the new Neocloud
ETF. Now Neo Cloud is some of the
smallest. The NBIS, the core, the IEL is
Hut and Wolf APLD. So watch this. AI
compute, GPU cloud, and data centers in
one ETF. I'm going to say it again. AI
compute, GPU cloud and data centers in
all in one ETF. It's by Roundill. Now
remember the Round Hill is the same
people that gave you what? Drum D RM.
Now I had a thing on here. So first of
all, let's talk about the biggest
portion of this is NBIS makes up 30%,
CRWV makes up 27%. Now I'm going to be
real with you. That is going to be H
that's going to be interesting. Now the
thing about that too is because you know
Nvidia is heavy in those two companies
as well. Now Roundtree been dropping
some stuff. Now here's what I just
learned. We now have more ETF
infrastructure. We have we more we now
have more ETF inflow than ever before.
So the ETF market is getting bred. It's
getting bred. Now, here's what I will
say for all my people that love AI.
Think about this. You can go drum.
You can go NCD
and you can go PSI
and you own a whole bunch of AI
without having to be in one lane,
right? meaning without having to be like
SNDK, MU, you know what I'm saying? In
the individuals, you can play the ETF
and that may be a safer way for you to
play the market going out to the year
out because think about it. Somebody
said earlier like trap, bro, them they
like trap them um what you call this be
kind of high for me, dog. Well, guess
what dram since $37. We made a lot. I
think we had drum at like 150%. But
think about you go dram at 5737 or
something that's cheaper than getting
what
SNDK or one of them. Fen you go NCLD
that's cheaper than getting NBS NBIS and
Coreweave and you get NBIS you get Core
Reeve you get Irene you get Hut you get
Wolf so you get AI compute leaders cloud
infrastructure leaders data center power
play leaders and future growth allin one
I might put my daughter up in this one I
might give Lely some of this one this
one and drum I may give Lely some of
this and drum I may go for a thousand
let me see something right quick how
much drum is right now.
Trauma is what? $57, $52, $54.
54 time [snorts] 600, that's 32,000.
Yeah, I could give her that. So, let me
see something. 54*
1,000
54. Yeah, we go a,000 a piece. Yeah.
Yeah. I I don't mind giving Lily that. I
could put that in that letter roll. I
could do that later roll. All right,
let's go a little further.
Let's go a little further. We just
talked about that one. All right, here
we go. Hedge funds purchasing US
equities in every trading session last
week. In total, the market in total,
this marked the second largest weekly
purchase of the last 12 months. Now, I
want I want to say this to y'all and
then when I say this, I want I want
y'all to think about what I'm about to
leave this to. So, think about the two
things I'm g say to y'all.
In total the this marked the second
largest weekly purchase over the last 12
months. Single stocks accounted for 70%
of the total of drop total driven
primarily by large equity purchase and
to the lessening extent short covering.
Information technology and communication
service saw the strongest demand with
eight of 11 sectors recording purchases.
Meanwhile, macro products such as index
futures and ETFs accounted for 30% of
the total demand with short positions in
ETF and US listings reduced for this
sixth week, hedge funds are doubling
down on US equities. Now, let me say
this.
Let me say this.
All last week, we saw hedge funds buying
stocks every day.
Let me just say this right quick. Let me
preface that with this.
This is why
a pullback today should not hurt you.
We saw heavy buying last week.
Yes, we did see a fall today.
Now, what you should look for is
is there consistent follow through?
Now, where you see followthrough going
to come at is
going to be predicated around
what do you see the 10 year doing?
Because if the 10ear keeps spiking,
stock market has nothing but no other
option but to what? Sell off. Now, let's
think about this two at the same time.
Let me say this. Let me preface that
with this. And this is where we got to
be careful at.
Think about this. Watch this.
The VIX today is only at 15,
which is low.
Let me do this.
The VIX is at 1584
and the fear and greed index is at 54 of
neutral
which means the market isn't in panic
mode. So neither should we.
I told Patreon this. I said, "Listen, we
had a six day runup
in total. You've been up two out of the
last three weeks
with a 10year that was at 4753
which mean we was almost at 80.
You going to sell off.
You going to sell off. Don't panic. And
so one of the things I try to teach my
people is this.
Like I try to teach my people this. Like
it's not how you respond to a green day.
It's how you respond to a red day.
Because a red day put you in worst case
scenario mind frame. Man, does that piss
me off when I get up and I see that big
ass gap down? Hell yeah. I'm not going
to act like I don't be pissed off about
that Like damn, bro. But I
understand it don't make me p espe if I
go down like I woke up this morning down
260.
Yesterday I was up like 190 and Friday I
was up like 150. You know what I'm
saying? So you wake up the morning on
three. You like damn I just ate two days
worth of earn is gone in in one day. All
right.
All right.
That then makes you say, "Let me go look
at structurally where am I?"
Right? So yes, that that that hit you in
your chest.
All right. Let me see structurally where
am I at though? Am I still holding
something? What did I give up? All
right, certain stocks gave up the 20
day. All right, cool. They gave up the
20, but they still hold structure.
Where's my stop loss at?
So, all of those things have to matter
to you, not just, oh man, I'm selling.
I'm selling. No, like give it a chance
and then if you say, "Okay, I can take
I'm gonna cut my loss small."
All you can say, I gave myself a little
time. Let the market, let me let the
market digest this,
right? That's another thing you got to
take in, man. Let me But here's what
hurt you. You see your thing down and
then you get on the market. You get on
Instagram. You see somebody made
$400.
You see somebody made
$600, $6,000. Somebody made 2,000%.
But you don't really know that they put
$20 up.
They got 500%. All right. You put $100
up. You made that cool. I'm not mad at
that at all either. What I am saying is
you can't let other people what they
doing influence what you got going on.
Because here's why.
You don't know what else was happening.
Did they lose three or four trades
before they made that one winning trade?
What type of losing streak were they on
before they did that?
Right, Shazam? That's where I'm at. I'm
at 30%. You know, that's my threshold.
Right? So that's what we got to keep in
mind. Also in this market, we can't be
greedy. You're not getting a 100% for
the week for swing trade. You're not
getting 100% right now. So if you get
30, 40%, but guess what? Your 30 40% on
a trade is the same as somebody who
probably put up $100, $200, $300,
$1,000.
You got your 30%. Like start measuring
what they doing to what you doing and
stick to what you have.
So, I wanted to just say that right
quick.
Let's go a little further.
All right. So, active traders versus the
Big 10, right? So, let's talk about that
for a minute.
All right. So, this is going to be
important for us, right? So nearly three
and four actively managed funds, US
large cap funds, which is what people
had their 401ks in at, failed, watch
this, failed to beat their passive
benchmarks over the past 12 months,
according to Morning Star, cited by the
Wall Street Journal. So these are these
are these are
trusted sources.
So I tell you your boy be really
searching for information for y'all.
Only 27% came out ahead after fees.
Even though wider differences between
individual stocks were supposed to be
greater battle in that environment for
stock picking. One problem is
concentration. The S&P 500's 10 largest
companies now make up more than 40% of
the index. So missing a few major tech
winners can quickly lead to active
managers falling behind. What does that
mean, trap?
The people who run your 401k,
the people who run your pension fund,
the people who run your TSP,
they're not beating the market. Three
out of four of them are failing.
And in total, in a one-year time span,
only 27% of funds came out ahead after
the fees.
That's your 401k.
So that mean if your 401k beating the
market in the 12 year time frame, 12-mon
time frame after fees, you're lucky
because about 73% of people didn't.
And I want you to put that in your brain
because this is why I always this is why
I push for us to learn how to manage our
own money.
The reason why I push for us to learn
how to manage our own money is simply
because
we don't have to pay a fee for us doing
our own money.
Somebody say, "My 401k is doing
awesome." Amazing. Again, 27%. You got
in that lucky 27%.
Right.
Somebody said it perfectly. My TSP is up
9%, but my buy and hold itself is up
30%. That's it.
Nobody
will do more for your money than you.
The goal is you haven't learned how to
trust yourself with this game. And I
promise you this for the person that
said that my full one is doing great. I
love that. But I bet you you could
outperform it.
>> H I'm just thinking what is you know
everybody's relative. What does great
mean? Yeah. Like you know when you
sitting on it. Yeah.
Somebody say, "What's amazing? Y'all so
crazy."
Right. You can outperform it because
what would happen if you didn't have to
pay them the fees,
right? So, I already know like we could
outperform that. She said, that person
said, "I am." And I knew it. If you on
trapping twos, I know you gonna
outperform your 401k.
And that's all I be wanting to say. Like
if you really took the time and just
say, you know what, I'mma put 12 to 15
companies in my in my own Roth IRA or in
my own account and every time they dip
hard, these the ones I'm buying. Like
you're going to outperform that 401k.
First of all, because you don't got to
pay no fees on it. Second of all,
because you're going to reinvest all
your dividends and your dividends going
to buy you more shares and so you going
to compound that
on down years. You double down on it.
You buy more of it. That way when it
recovers, you can have up more. You will
100% beat your 401k
because you just understand you don't
need everything that they have in there
and you don't need to pay them to do it.
And so that's my goal. My goal is I want
us to be able to play this game. I want
us to trust ourselves. And I want us to
have the confidence not to just like not
to just put our retirement in our own
hands, but to put our own financial
future in our own hands from a
perspective of we are
And then what happens is we start doing
it for ourselves. We start doing it for
our kids. We start doing it for our
wives. We start doing for our husbands.
And then we start building like you can
have your full you can have your own
Roth IRA, your husband Roth IRA. Then
y'all got a family fund. Something that
y'all doing for each other. Then y'all
do one for the kids. Then y'all have an
account that y'all trade with. Like I
ain't gonna lie. I'mma just be 100% real
with you. One of my one of my biggest
things like that I want to do like is I
want to
um like you know God bless me with a
family like I want to be able to like
look at my girl and be like hey let's
trade together.
You know what I'm saying? Like I'mma
help you with your your thing to help
you catch up. But then I want us to
trade together. I want you to be looking
at Detroit. You know we building
businesses. We learn how to trade. You
know, I think it's something so dope.
Like you in, you know, whatever with
your girl and you bring a laptop, like,
"Hey, let's make a trade right quick."
Or she like, "Let's get on a chart right
quick." I think people that do that, I
think like making money with your
partner has to be such a
love language,
>> different level of intimacy.
>> You know what I'm saying? That's the
word I'm looking for. It has to be such
an intimate thing. Like, damn, we just
made [clears throat] some money
together. Because I was telling somebody
like I was telling my girl Donnie this
uh I was like man because we was talking
about Alex her Mosa and his wife and I
said
he don't make the$und00 million without
her
that weekend when they did $108 million
in the weekend bro
she pregnant now
goes the way
>> after 100 million together. Of course
she did.
>> Yeah.
>> Because even on the webinar, she was on
the webinar.
>> She was cooking.
So I I know for a fact, bro, like there
is nothing
like there's I'm not gonna say nothing,
but that has to be like such a
phenomenal feeling when like you can,
you know, build your business like with
your lady
or y'all trading together
or you helping with her business because
it's a different communication than
saying, and nothing against entre,
nothing against people that go to work
on a 9 to5 or nothing like that, but
like
even this, I saw this dude on Instagram
say this and I thought this was so dope.
He said
he said his wife, his girl called him
and was like, "Be this job pissing me
off." Y So I guess he was an
entrepreneur. He was like, "Man, quit
that damn job." And she like, "I ain't"
He said, "Guess what? how much you get
paid this month. Take the month off. I'm
depositing that in your in your account.
And I said, "Bro, that's cold blooded."
He was like, "How much you get paid this
month?" All right, bet. He called her
back. He was like, "Go look at your
account." She looked at the account like
whatever she got paid that month, he put
it in her account. He was like, "Now
quit the job.
He know take this month off."
I was like, "Damn,
damn."
But he was an entrepreneur and she, you
know, was working the job or whatever.
But I just think that that may be
something so cool to be able to be like
even if she got a job and you
entrepreneur, Boto got a job, like y'all
like I see people do real estate
together. Like I see working families
that go buy real estate together and
then But no, let me ask you a question.
You do real estate. Dude, you and your
girl do real estate together. You feel
me? I think that is so dope
cuz like he might focus on the building
and she probably like the interior part
like that may be her thing like all
right babe you go do this I ain't really
tripping I'mma buy it. I'm a negotiator
and then all the interior stuff that's
you
like I think that is the thing that can
keep I think first there's the religious
component or the spiritual component and
then I think there's that that money
making becomes like such a intimate
thing
y'all can sit down like I be saying to
people on Instagram like yo we having
our quarterly financial meet and they go
out the house, they go rent like an
Airbnb. And I'm like, bro, that got to
be so gangster.
But that shows intentionality
on where you want the relationship to go
because if we can't talk about money
together, we we not going to be able to
navigate these tough times that's going
to come because they going to come.
Economy going to go through stuff.
Recessions going to happen. If we don't
talk about money, then we don't know the
stability of our family.
And if we don't know the stability of
our family, then we building our house
on sand and not on rock.
And so a ocean wave is on its way to
take us down.
And so earlier we talked about it always
being about us. Like one of the things
that has to be prevalent in the black
community is money talks have to stop
being taboo.
Y'all go to church together. Y'all go to
dinner together. Y'all go shopping
together. Y'all go on trips together.
But y'all don't want to talk about money
together.
You don't You don't want to ask what's
your credit score?
You don't want to ask, you know, what
are your financial? Watch this. What are
the things that hurt you financially?
What are the things that you scared of
financially?
Like tell me some of your experiences
with money. Are you a saver or are you a
spender? Are you a risktaker? Or are you
conservative?
Because if we don't know these things,
then we don't know how we going to like
watch this. We don't know if we got
financial compatibility.
You like, "Yeah, bro. She fine. She
pretty." Yeah, bro. But like, can she
save some bread?
Is she spinning the bread? And she
looking at him like, "Not he handsome,
but can he go to make some money?
Can he legally?
Can he make some money legally? Like if
y'all in a jam, can he come up with the
vision like, "Hey, check this out. We
about to I'm about to go cut this grass
right quick. I'm about to start this
lawn care company. I'm going to cut this
grass." And will you be like, "Yep. I'm
going to gas the tanks up, too.
Are you Are you going to get the
lawnmowers? I'm going to go find a cage
and put on the back of the truck that we
can do it. I'm going to make the signs
get like
that's it."
like can I bring you the bread home and
because we've learned how to invest I
know you invest in the money or do we
learn this together like hey babe I
don't really hey let's take this course
together
that's one thing I wish I seen a lot of
in my in the mentorships that we do
but what the mentorships I pay for
I see it a lot
like and the mentorship that I'm paying
like 30,000 50,000 60,000 for even when
I Hey, brotherund. They had like people
in there with their wife like, "Hey, we
I'm with my wife. I'm with my husband.
He does this. I does this." Like one of
my one of the people I'm cool with from
the mentorship, him and his wife just
sold his business for $80 million.
And he come to me, he said, "Trap, bro.
We just sold a business for 80 million.
I was able to keep 35 million and 2% of
the company. I need to know I
[clears throat] need to know how to put
10 million in the market." Trap.
I was like, "I got you, bro."
He did the They had a roofing company.
His wife did all the calls. She put the
whole sales team and she put that
together. He put the physical part
together. I was like, "Damn, that's so
cold blooded." Imagine y'all built this
company from scratch. You sell it for 80
million. You keep 30 something million
and you keep 2% of the company. You and
your wife did that.
That's the game, bro. So, fellas, if you
trading, bro, teach your girl how to
trade
or teach her how to do the buy and hold
while you learning how to or why you
trade. Walk her through how you trading
so she can learn.
And I see that as some of the biggest
downfalls I talk about a lot of
I remember watching some of my homies
hustle but then when they fell off or
went to prison the whole family fell off
cuz you ain't taught your girl how to do
nothing cuz you gave her the soft life
and now she don't know how to do nothing
but
you know what that's about to lead to
she going to go try to find another
hustler.
So, one of the things for us as Stellas
is like we got to learn how to lead, but
like also like financial compatibility.
What does that look like?
What does that look like? Well, you
rocking with somebody that like you can
teach what you doing, but also somebody
you can learn from what they doing.
And with that, I'mma end the show, man.
It's your boy Wall Street Chopper, man.
Episode 206 is in the books, man.
Another great episode, man. Freedom
without discipline equals destruction.
And I guess I'll talk about that another
time. Yeah. Um but let's go, man. Um
same time, same place next week, man. Um
[music] get your merch. We got merch on
fire. We got merch on sale that's
popping. Um that's a thing. Um man,
somebody said, "I've always been an
independent man, bro. We can only go so
far independent, [music] man. I'll be
real with you, bro.
We going to go so far independent, bro.
We wasn't designed to be that way. Also,
man, check out some of the other shows
we got, man, on the Wall Street Trapper
page. Go check out that one we dropped
last night. We got some more dropping
tomorrow. Come join the Patreon, man.
Come rock out with us. Y'all already
know. Come join Trappers Anonymous Rock
already know. Get your merch, but also
um go download us on all of the
platforms. It's your boy Wall Street
Chopper. I'll see y'all same time, same
place next week, man. Salute. [music]
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
[music]
Heat. Heat. N. [music]
>> [music]
[music]
>> Heat.
Hey. Hey. Hey. Heat. Heat.
[music]
Heat. Heat. N.
>> [music]
[music]